e
e e
uh good morning it's uh it's 10 o'clock
I'm going to open this morning's uh uh
division work session for division three
of Finance uh today's topic is the
division of Public Health Services I see
um Deputy or associate Deputy
Commissioner Patricia Tilly associate
but thank you associate okay uh along
with Mr Nathan white so so um I don't
have any uh precursor comments for today
um so I'll let you just jump in great do
you want start sure uh good morning
Nathan white Chief Financial Officer
with the Department of Health and Human
Services uh so today we'll be going over
the division of Public Health Services
budget um it begins on page
98 of the governor's operating
budget
and Public Health Services has about a
100 accounts uh so it's it's fairly
lengthy and that that will run all the
way through Page
984 and then as usual you have the
budget briefing book before you it's a
66-page document again only the
accounting units in excess of a million
dollars and I will hand it over to
Trisha for today's presentation so good
morning thank you Nathan good morning
thank you chair thank you members of the
committee um I am sitting in today for
director Ian watt he had a family
emergency so I am pinch hitting at the
last moment so I hope that you will be
uh patient with me as I find some of the
answers as we go through um I am also
represented today by a number of folks
from the division of Public Health
Services that are sitting in the gallery
so when I Stumble we can be able to call
on them for some expertise um as well
you have heard a lot about DHHS over the
past several weeks and I have been
impressed with your questions and with
your stamina as you get through all of
these reports the breadth and depth of
the department is
extraordinary um of the major divisions
Public Health has the smallest budget of
the big divisions it has the smallest
budget and only a modest fraction of
General funds within it um it is mainly
supported by federal funds and by other
funds that often come through fees or
licensing or some other capacity um but
Public Health also comes with a great
deal of complexity so what it makes up
for in you know a relatively small
budget when you're comparing it to
Medicaid or behavioral health or
economic Services it is incredibly
complex and or at least the breath is
wide as Nathan noted we have almost 100
accounting units in it there's over 50
federal grants a lot of the work happens
through contract so there's a lot of
detail that you could be interested in
as you make your decisions and and um
consider your options in front of you
when you think about this budget there
were no significant um cuts to Public
Health in the governor's budget so
that's helpful for you to know straight
up front um other than the unfund of
several positions the biggest
uncertainty for public health right now
is what's happening at the federal level
so you know we like all of you are
waiting for clarity and direction from
the federal government as they switch
their priorities and as they think about
what it is that they want to um invest
in and where are there areas that they
may be turning away from so we are
waiting
like everyone else um and especially
when you think about the fact that we
have over 50 federal grants um within
the division of Public Health that
creates some uncertainty for us that
said we've presented a budget here and
the governor has presented a budget that
assumes the work that we are doing will
continue on um I hope you will see over
the next couple of hours that both the
department and public health care about
the same things that you care about and
the things that your neighbors care
about about clean water about safe food
about preventing our kids and our loved
ones and your neighbors from getting
sick as well as stretching and
conserving all of our limited resources
as you flip to our mission on slide two
can I I I I want to do a a setup
question now and and having talked to
you for a lot the last few years I'm I'm
sure this is going to be easy for you
but but going going into this section
there are a significant number of of
people
taxpayers that say very simply and very
generally that uh the public health
budget that's being presented has grown
significantly since uh before covid and
that there really ought to be an effort
to return it back to preco like era in
size and you and I have talked about it
I think you have uh an answer but can
you give us your sort of one paragraph
or two paragraph summary of of how you
respond to that sort of simple belief
sure thanks that's a great question so
again we all experienced we had the
pre-co days the pre-pandemic days there
was work there was Federal resources
like crazy we had arpa dollars
everything stretched not only Public
Health but every all of our work across
the Department of Health and Human
Services been benefited by um uh in an
influx of funds from the federal
government we stretched it up and those
funds have now receded so it's I at
early on I was calling it the title
waver the tsunami we knew the tsunami
was coming and then eventually that
tsunami was going to flow backwards and
that's where we are right now so what we
I can tell you you know full-time
authorized staff we're about exactly
where we were 2018 so we had about 250
staff then we have about 250 staff now
there are some federal funds that have
continued to flow into the department
that have added some increase but the
other place that you'll see where we've
increased is just by shifting things
around in the department as well as with
other agencies so you'll recall When I
Was Here a number of weeks ago we talked
about how um for example our Bureau uh
for emergency preparedness response and
Recovery that was in a whole other
section of the department we moved it
into the division of Public Health and
therefore it looks like we had a budget
increase but when you look across the
the department it is the same similarly
and I was had the ability to tune in a
little bit to your conversations with
the division for Economic Security
yesterday and with director Hebert we
have some uh programs that used to be
supported or uh budgeted and funded and
and supported within Economic Security
that have now or dcyf that have now
moved over into public health so there
has been a shifting of where some of the
things are that gives the impression
that the budget has increased but you
have to look at it across the entire
department so so to that end I I was
anticipating that as part of your answer
the the the consolidation of other
programs into the public health as we go
through the budget over the next couple
hours would you try to make a point so
we don't have to keep asking you sure if
there's a program that has moved where
did it move from and and you know what
the underlying rationale for the move
was absolutely happy to do that thank
you and I'll also highlight to the best
that I can just eyeball it where there
might be new federal Investments where
they weren't before 2018 I may not be
able to get all of them or have a
completely comprehensive list but I bet
I can eyeball some of them for you all
right uh thank you I'm looking forward
to this super thanks so if you flipped
to uh slide two this is our mission and
you'll see that one of the things that
sets Public Health apart from other
places within the department is that its
mission is to serve every single person
in the state so we have great programs
like medic or long-term services that
serve vulnerable populations incredibly
important Public Health on the other end
by its nature serves the entire
population and we do that by making sure
your food is safe we make we do that by
making sure the dental x-ray that you
use that the dentist is safe and we do
that by other population Health measures
we also have some targeted programs we
have some targeted programs like the
wick program the women infant and
children feeding program or we have
other programs that serve other vulner
able or lowincome populations but as a
whole the the mission of the department
really is to protect and promote the
health of everyone in the state of New
Hampshire so um as you go to slide three
you'll begin to see that breath from
emergency response as um representative
Edwards noted to surveillance of
infectious disease to targeting
strategies that we know are going to
improve health we support directly folks
like the federal equal qualified Health
Centers our community health centers we
support small hospitals with um
activities around quality improvement we
focus on chronic disease prevention and
maternal and child health things that I
you know that many of us are starting to
think are going to be continued to be
supported in a new federal
Administration we've heard a lot about
that from the feds right now around the
emphasis on chronic disease we
anticipate a continued focus on maternal
Health we also collect and analyze data
about the health status of community
needs and the strengths within those
communities and we use that dat data to
determine where we should focus our
resources and finally you know the way
that I think about it is that public
health really is an invisible glue it's
helping us stay healthy we are often at
our best when we're not in the newspaper
when you don't have to think about us
when your medical providers are close by
and you have access to care when your
food and water doesn't make you sick you
know when your child's school is not
interrupted by an outbreak of measles
that's when we're doing our job you can
go out and eat in the community with
little concern about or go out and be in
the community with little concern of
getting tuberculosis or breathing
Legionella in from some sort of water
holding tank you know your milk and your
coffee is safe that's the mission of um
the division of Public Health Services
so let's get started and we'll do a
little work into the organizational
overview on Slide Five you'll see
roughly where those bureaus are um we
have a director's office and again um
director watt send his regrets about not
being here today um and there are some
programs within that director's office
and then we have a bureau of family
health and nutrition a bureau of
Infectious Disease Control a bureau of
Public Health protection our Bureau of
emergency preparedness response recovery
our Bureau of prevention and wellness
Bureau of public health statistics and
informatics and finally our Public
Health Laboratories we currently have
about a 15% vacancy rate across all of
those programs within in the division um
slide six you'll recognize from when I
was here a couple of weeks ago these are
the bureaus that have generally stayed
the same in size and focus our lab our
Bureau of infectious disease our Bureau
of public health statistics and
informatics and our Bureau of Public
Health protection those have generally
stayed within the same scope um and look
the same and organizationally are the
same um since pre pandemic did you take
a question from representative
priest thank you Mr chairman and welcome
Mrs til and um thank you for everything
that you do um for the agency and for
all the public health um we've been
hearing a lot about the bird flu virus
and I know this is just an open question
but where would something like this fall
within the organizational chart that's a
super question and it speaks to the way
that our work is integrated you know
while we have all these different
bureaus our work crosses over every day
so for bird flu and not only within the
division of Public Health Services but
also with our other state agency
partners so when we think about bird
through there's two things there's the
human health aspect which is impact
which we focus on within um the division
of Public Health Services and the
Department of Health and Human Services
and then there's the animal health part
of it which actually we partner with the
Department of Agriculture for so
together working with the Department of
a we focus within the division of Public
Health is thinking about um safety of
food so safety of the milk Pro milk um
that we have right now so we do some
testing the FDA has requested us and
USDA has requested us to do some work
around testing of milk supply to make
sure that the bird flu is not in the
milk as you know as many of you have
followed this the birds can impact the
other animals that dairy cows within the
community um and then ultimately if
there were to be human infections that's
where both our laboratory and our Bureau
of infectious disease and our Bureau of
emergency preparedness would all kick in
you'll see as we get to some of those um
for example when we get to the Bureau of
emergency preparedness we actually have
a slot of budgeted amount of money that
is unfunded from the feds but we leave
it there for emergency so so that if the
feds were to send us emergent money so
that we could have a response if there
was a reason for a response we could
accept that money quickly and then
deploy it thank you very much thank you
so slides um okay I'll move on um slides
seven through nine again are a repeat
from when I was here a couple of weeks
ago and they show how we reorganized
existing work and Incorporated it from
the other parts of the department um I
will ask representative Edwards would
you like me to go through this detail
again now or should we skip through or
there questions I just don't want to
take up your time repeating so my Hope
was that the prior uh educational form
that you provided us is is enough
background for us to get more into the
metrics and of the of the of what your
programs are doing sure and if there are
questions because we forget uh about
what the program is really intended to
do you know maybe you could just give us
a sentence introduction and and then hit
hit how we do it and how much resource
consumption there is sure and so I think
we can probably get to that as we dig
into the budget so this so I think 7
through n just as that background of how
the deck chairs got moved around so if
we SL go to slide 10 you know this is
where we start getting to those key
budget takeaways um you'll see again the
relatively modest um budget when you're
comparing it to other parts of the
department um like Medicaid or long-term
services and of that budget um less than
20% % is General funds so not a lot of
money there to move around as you all
are doing the hard work of making some
really hard decisions around um making
your overall state budget work so
probably a question for Mr White for
context uh the general funds that go to
Public Health what percentage of the
total Department of Health and Human
Services are these General funds do
these General funds represent 5% of the
total general fund demand hand of the
department or or whatever the numberers
do you know and if you don't know right
away you could just tell us later
but sure so if if you look at the uh the
governor's operating budget page 984
you'll see there's a proximately $24
million of General funds budgeted in all
of Public Health you and and and you'll
you'll notice that the federal funds are
around $135 million so pretty
significant when you compare that to the
total
DHHS general fund operating budget in
the governor's recommended budget it's
$1.1
billion so so today we're talking about
24 million of 1.1 billion so we're
around 2.2% of the total DHHS relatively
ininal amount yes yeah okay good good
context it's maybe a rounding error is
the way that I would describe it
representative seaworth thank you Mr
chairman I'd like to jump ahead a little
bit too since we're we're doing that of
this um 18% General funds is it mostly
again either matching funds and
maintenance of effort or is there a mix
between what it's used for so there's um
a number of Standalone grants that do
not have a matching or maintenance of
effort um there are allocated costs for
certain positions where individuals work
on certain grants and those funds um are
are allocated but but that may be from a
fixed Grant in certain cases it may be
from um from for and other cases and it
all depends on the nature of the work um
but this works a little Public Health
overall generally speaking is a little
different there are matching
requirements for certain grants but it
depends on the grants so it's uh it's
it's very Grant specific where we have
dozens and dozens of them within Public
Health and they're they're much smaller
and that's part of the reason that you
know we don't have 12 accounting units
we have 100 because we have to track
each one of those separately and you'll
see those as we go through the budget
just just for broad
context and again as I can eyeball as we
go through I'll sort of highlight when
there's an accounting unit that has
General funds and federal funds in it I
think we can eyeball and number those
and go that's a match that's a
maintenance of effort those are
resources that were invested
is it also true that in um the 66 page
DHHS budget briefing book for public
health that those kinds of answers can
all be found in in this detail or is
that overlooked occasionally you know
what I would expect that most of those
details are in there I would never say
that anything is completely ACC
completely complete so you you do have a
resource uh representative NV thank you
Mr chairman thank you Mr Telly uh I'm
looking at uh 9008 the St starting page
here I'm looking at the uh number of
positions which looks like it's you know
close to doubled and I'm I'm assuming
that that's part of the reorganiza where
some of those positions in other places
move from other places and that would
see a corresponding offset yes is that
okay thank Youk and and for General
context if you did look at if you turn
to page
984 that summarizes the total count of
positions for the division and you'll
actually see a net reduction of one
unclassified position to the total count
so there will be movement within the
accounting units but broadly speaking
the the numbers are remaining
neutral and a quick
followup so of the positions how many of
those are are
unfilled we have about a 15% vacancy
rate right now and that's a broad number
across um but it's in that ballpark okay
thank you thank you so so so I'd like to
follow up on that I uh because uh
Manpower costs are are significant part
of every budget um uh is the following
accurate that uh in the last two budget
years uh the entire department has had
three a ceiling of 3,000 full-time
permanent employees imposed on it and
that in the governor's budget the
governor asked how many vac encies are
were Department wide the number was
450 and so uh she's asked in her budget
to reduce by 400 so effectively you have
a
2600 Manpower ceiling for the coming
budget is is is that is that accurate no
part of it is part this is what I'm why
I'm asking sure so um and I I can
provide a little bit of History so in
the prior Bia we in in chapter law um
there was a
3,000 cap and that's full-time
authorized position cap that was
established in the current Bia chapter
79 or chapter 106 laws of 2023 there's a
current 3,000 full-time authorized
position cap and both and both those
Provisions were chapter law that chapter
law expires on June 30th of
2025 in the governor's operating bu
budget there was uh 394 positions that
were
unfunded so if you look at our total
count where we are right now or where we
were a couple weeks ago we were around
2800 filled positions and so that
remaining Delta of the 450 or so of that
the 394 were
unfunded okay and and the reason I bring
that department level question into this
conversation is I think we're going to
have this ongoing interest in in how the
the the Manpower in each of these
programs are affected and I assume that
um they've all been um prioritized by
the
commissioner of what her available
Manpower might be and the and and and in
this budget book we we're seeing the um
and a a transitory position of the
department or is this your sort of your
your go forward position that you want
the division to division three to assess
reassess sure so um I I I guess two two
points on that one is I think it's
important to just to recognize that our
budget our our Personnel costs are about
11% so we're very different from most
agencies where Personnel Drive their
costs often times like at Department
Corrections Department of Safety um very
different in that sense um and yesterday
we haded talked about that one piece of
Statute that this committee had made
permanent uh the authority to fill
unfunded positions in hb2 of last year
and we're very grateful for that and
then the other key provision there
that's in the current draft is the
provision to move money from person
within Personnel lines and so the
positions are unfunded But ultimately
we're a very Dynamic operation and needs
arise and they Decline and it's those
two key Provisions that will allow us to
manage through the next bium with those
unfunded positions those are very
important provisions and if we didn't
have those then we would be locked into
the current state and it would be very
difficult to respond to emerging needs
uh as they come about so so I think I
think the division wanted you to have
that flexibility because we we
anticipated the challenge that we were
imposing on you but uh but one thing uh
that maybe you could clarify and again
I'm sorry to distract this is the
department wide and it affects you as
well is let let's say you have um three
positions that you consider a priority
but as you look at the available money
you think you can only really fund two
of them are you allowed under the
current rules to go and advertise for
all three
simultaneously and just fill the first
two that can be filled and shut down
recruitment on the third or or do you
have to have a fully funded position
each and every one before you can go
recruit so traditionally you need to
have the position funded in order to
post it um I know that DCF has worked
out um certain solutions that Marie
Nunan had made reference to the other
day as far as finding other Alternatives
so that you you didn't if you had a 100
vacancies you could post 100 positions
um we would have to work uh with the
with the division of personnel to see if
we could do that in other areas because
that kind of it it breaks the logic of
the system like 1 plus one must equal
two um but but we've been able to do
that successfully in certain areas and
we would we'll probably need to see if
we can expand that to other areas so
that we we have the ability to hire
because if you can't post you're never
going to higher and you're going to see
that that rate go that vacancy rate go
up right so so this this is kind what
I'm trying to offer is is that uh I
assume having the flexibility to recruit
simultaneously for more positions than
you have available funding for and then
to control the recruitment process to
shut down when you obligated the money
against new hires that that would that
additional flexibility would would help
in some cases
it it it helps greatly it's just a
question if you need that in an hb2 if
you don't have quite that flexibility I
you know help us uh draft that because I
I think that would be fair um to say
okay you you got four important
positions but only money for two go open
it up and and see see what we can get
and then stop the other two if you run
out of money sure I I'd like to have a
conversation with our peers at the
department of administrative Services
just understand what would potentially
be needed there and and make sure that
we we partner with them to make it
successful sure and I'm willing to
partner with all of you on that um so uh
so I'm sorry that was a huge segue that
got triggered by a question on Personnel
but I I I I wanted to have us sort of
see a a bigger picture as we look at all
those we appreciate that uh
representative go ahead yeah thank you
Mr chairman a really quick uh
definitional question so you talk in
terms of full-time positions is that the
same as uh full-time equivalents I mean
I'm kind of used to and um that would in
include the number you gave if it was
full-time equivalence would include
part-time or
temporary so there's different types of
positions in the state system one is
your your standard classified positions
and you'll see the salaries budgeted
within uh class 10 for that
then you'll see unclassified positions
um unclassified positions are at will
positions they're established in RSA
941a and those are budgeted at DHHS
within Class 12 um they're other
agencies budget them in class 11 I
believe there's also non-classified
positions which we currently have none
of which don't exist in statute and then
there's also full-time temporary
positions which are typically budgeted
Within class 59 and then there's
part-time temporary positions which are
budgeted within class
50 and just to note for public health we
have a number of those um temporary
positions we sometimes refer to them as
n9s or 8s um which are not part of that
full-time authorized we have those
temporary positions because they're
often tied to a Time limited Grant and
so the money is just good for when we
have those federal funds the there's no
expectation necessar that that position
is going to be a permanent position
within the department so just so when
I'm looking at the numbers in the
governor's budget book and I you know um
I'm not seeing the whole picture of how
many people were employing because it it
doesn't include those those different
categories of yeah so the the numbers
that you see in there those are the
full-time authorized positions that
include the classified and unclassified
typically the full-time temporary
positions or the part-time temporary
positions um those have much higher
vacancy rates those are either
established via a dop and GNC process
for extension or they're approved bya
fiscal committee when we receive funding
uh for a certain
purpose okay thank you I I think the
other thing you're not seeing in that is
is that some of these programs are
supported through uh contracts and the
contracts provide Manpower with many of
them so so you're not seeing a a a
complete Manpower
picture so I'm also not seeing a
Complete Personnel cost picture because
it's a portion of that is buried in the
contracts yeah you say Personnel I say
Manpower it's so just it's probably the
same thing yep thank
you thank you so um if we want to move
along we can go into slide 11 which
starts getting to some of those you know
at least ke achievements and some of
those numbers that are not budget
numbers that I know that you're
interested in thinking about um you know
at the top of the list we have our
nationally recognized laboratory a
phenomenal facility it's up on 29 Hazen
drive we have tested over 16,000 water
samples in 2024 including 2500 from
public Wells to ensure that we have
clean water for both to drink and to
play in we have launched our Wastewater
surveillance program with support from
the federal government to monitor for
respiratory diseases is in local
communities it's one of my f you know um
those of you who know me I love pulling
up data slides it's great to go in and
sort of see where the um the spikes are
of respiratory illness that shows up in
your Wastewater this is also an
important technology because it is
anticipated that there could be uses for
other infectious diseases that can be um
that can be noticed or figured out
through through Wastewater so it's a
great um system to have in place now
that we may need for something else in
the future that we don't even know
about we um conduct food testing to
maintain that safe food supply including
Dairy and shellfish shellfish that is
grown right off the shores of New
Hampshire one of the things that was
interesting and again incredible value
of our laboratory this year in the past
year in 2024 we identified some arsenic
in a apple juice box so any of you who
have kids or grandkids you know about
little juice boxes we identified arsenic
in that that led to a recall of more
than 14,000 cases of juice across 26
States really protecting the health
especially of the small children that
drink that product so then we look at so
that's our sort of laboratory fun you
know get in there there's no more bunts
and burners but in my mind I I always
still want to see like bunts and burners
as I walk through that laboratory we
also have delivered oversight and
resources um around for our communities
and our environment and some of that is
through our regulatory work and
Licensing work so we've licensed over 60
6,000 businesses including restaurants
and others food providers we've
conducted more than 3500 routine and
licensing inspections every year to
ensure that safe food supply we've
processed over 28,000 um blood lead
level results for adults and kids and
provided case management when kids or
youth or and adults have high levels of
um Le blood lead in their blood we've
inspected more than 46 radiation
machines and conducted some Associated
registra of activities and distributed
did more than 3500 radon tests free at
free cost I have I have a question about
416 the I I assume that nearly all of
those are Diagnostic Imaging machines
often referred to as x-ray machines so
um yes and actually you can take a look
later on when we get there we actually
have a pie chart further later in the
presentation of the span some of them
are industry as well those radiation
machines that are are that could be in
Industry so it's not only in healthcare
environments but in industrial settings
okay and and so even if um an
organization has a
physicist um on staff uh we still have
an obligation to go do an independent
yes test it does that does that make
sense in a resource constraint
environment are there situations where
we could ask the organizational
physicist to to conduct and
self-certify safety of of Diagnostic
Imaging systems I I think think all
things are on the table to have that
discussion we've actually had some other
thoughts around our rad health program
to to ease some of that is a the way in
which we license in particular dental
equipment that we think that there's an
opportunity and we've actually shared it
with um Cod that to streamline that
because many of the um pieces of
equipment that we go to are in dental
providers and so I think there's some
opportunities there I think for health
Rel especially for health related
environments you always will want an
dependent body to come in and make sure
that those machines are working as they
should be okay I'm I'm glad you're
working with coach and you've got ideas
already TR keep coming thank you thank
you so much and then again we get to
some of the other places in public
health that you might was there I'm
sorry was there a question a question
representative Daniels yes thank you of
the 3500 uh free test how many how many
of those test uh we were results were
reported back to the division um I I
don't know and I can find out and the
team that's sitting here can figure can
help me with this they don't require
that we find out the results of what
happened with those tests we send the
tests out to the family to the
individuals and the homeowners and they
use it we don't there's no reporting re
back to us what those tests found am I
understanding your question correctly
yes but I guess it leads to the question
so you really have no idea if they're
being used or not you know what I'll
I'll get back to you on the way in which
we evaluate that okay thank you you're
welcome
thank you and then finally um the other
area that we're really proud of is some
of the work that we've done around
family support and yesterday I had the
opportunity to tune into um director
Hebert's presentation and we were
talking a little bit about tanif and the
ways in which it can be used to support
young families I know representative
Edwards you're interested in the two
family you know what we're doing to
support two families we're going to talk
about that a little bit later in the
presentation but we are using tanif
funds um in part as well with federal
funds and General funds to really
provide the sort of preventative
Services that I talked a lot about the
last time that I was here around what we
can be doing to make sure that we keep
kids and families safe healthy happy and
preferably nowhere near the child
welfare system so those are the areas in
which we're particularly proud this year
as you go into slide 13 you'll see that
we're going to start digging into the
budget now and what those numbers are so
we have as noted um our Administration
our office of the director leads and
supports seven bureaus this is where we
dump all the rent all of the um other
you know overall costs for there it's
largely driven by um cost allocated
funds however we also include and in
addition we include folks like our
legislative liais on many of you know
Abby Rogers she sits within our office
of director we have our state
epidemiologist Dr Ben Chan again many of
you know him from TV and our therapeutic
cannabis program our therapeutic
cannabis program is one of those
programs that's moved around a little
bit um it came to the department well
before the pandemic it used to be split
all the functions of it were split
across the department um 2016 is we
brought it to um public health and
combined it into one program so as you
flip into so C idea is is do you
anticipate a time where the therapeutic
cannabis program can just be spun out of
state government and privatized
to run on a as sort of an independent
organization or or do you see the state
always having to play the a role similar
uh to what we're playing now that's a
great question I haven't I have not
thought about it in that way well you're
not using therapeutic
cannabis a
little that's
private we keep that data very private
yeah I I i' I've been watching this
program for for now the fifth term and
it just seems to me at some point we can
exit this business um all right there's
a and I think there are ways in which to
think about therapeutic cannabis we do
provide you know the structure of
ensuring that um New Hampshire's program
is not like other states there are other
states where it is very easy to get a
card and it's just it's very permissive
New Hampshire's program is a little bit
more restrictive and conservative in its
approach that might not lend it itself
to an outside entity do you have a
question represent I just have a comment
I uh participated in a tour of um one of
these therapeutic cannabis um uh
locations it was extremely eye openening
um the amount of um control and um you
know eyes on making sure everything is
is safe and um appropriately documented
and everything I encourage everyone to
reach out and tour one of these
facilities it really was impressive it's
really extraordinary the work and you
know I'll just underscore what you noted
around safety one of the roles of Public
Health is to make sure that people are
getting what they think that they're
getting and that there are not additives
or adulterations to the product that's
the difference of why it's worth um
paying the $50 for every three years
it's not a heavy amount of money for
someone to register if they have a their
if they have a condition that qualifies
them and they know they're getting safe
um a safe product which you're certainly
not going to get on the black market and
you may or may not get as much with a
retail Market that doesn't have
oversight over
it so um as you flip you'll see on uh
slide 15 um a little few little graphs
about the therapeutic um cannabis um
program we're close to 15,000 folks
right now registered that's huge when
you did you intend to skip page 14 or
did we do 14 and I just out you know
what I did not intend to skip page 14 I
just got excited about the therapeutic
cannabis program all right I could spend
six hours talking to you about the
therapeutic cannabis program so uh page
14 you'll see the office of director
those funds are are largely cost
allocated across the program and then
you'll see about the 1.2 million that's
the therapeutic cannabis program those
are not General funds those are not
State funds those are funds um that are
uh come through both registration fees
as well as um there's in statute the
ability for those alternative treatment
um at atcs alternative treatment centers
to make whole the program so there are
no General there are no federal funds in
that program it is
self-funded we can now get to page 15
and I can show off our slides our our
data you'll see the steady increase over
time of enrollment in that program and
that really has come with the increase
of um understanding about it and sort of
um people learn about it but the other
thing that has increased the growth is
the number of conditions that have been
certified that folks can have to be
certified in the program you'll recall
in many of the conversations this is not
a prescription Physicians do not
prescribe Med the therapeutic cannabis
they simply certify that you have one of
a list of conditions and that's what
makes you eligible of note at the bottom
I I I always think this is interesting
some of us have a vision of who uses
cannabis um you'll see the per capita
rate around the the U total Patti
patients by County you'll see the county
with the highest per capita rate of use
is Coos County and we attribute that
mostly to the age of coas County most of
the the um age cohort of the people in
the therapeutic can cannabis program
tends to be older older middle class uh
not middle class older middle age um
those folks you know starting at about
age 50 those are the that's the area and
because coas has a higher median age
rate it's not surprising in to see that
higher rate up North so that bottom one
confuses me a little bit three atcs and
seven locations and while you're
addressing that uh would you also
address whether or not uh the state
would benefit from having a mobile ATC
capability it hasn't been allowed by law
yep I so um it has not been allowed by
law I think access is always important
um and I think there are probably ways
you could control for that for security
we want to make sure that you know part
of what the program and why it isn't a
separate program privatized is that we
want to ensure there's no diversion of
the product so we would have to ensure
that there was security for that so that
certainly is something that we could
think about in a more um in a stronger
way so to the three ic's in four in
seven locations the state was divided
into four quadrants when the program was
um developed there are three vendors for
those four quadrants one has two areas
in the others each have their own area
um and over time it when it was
originally developed there was only one
retail location in each of those
quadrants um over time we have expanded
that to try and make um access a little
bit easier so there are three entities
who have contracts with the state to
provide to be the ATC they are in seven
retail
locations so um do we have any evidence
that suggests that the availability of
therapeutic cannabis has an impact on
reducing the number of medical
Pharmaceuticals that are being consumed
because we spend a lot of money on
medical Pharmaceuticals and there's a
lot of anecdotal discussion around how
people can use therapeutic cannabis and
get off of pharmaceuticals it's it it's
a super question what we don't you know
we haven't been able to for legal
reasons we have not been able to match
you know the people in this registry
with you know prescribing habits and and
I'm not sure that would always be
perfect anyway because of the folks in
this program by definition are sick they
have a condition of some sort they may
have cancer and there may be lots of
things that they are prescribed at any
given time however what we do have is we
do an annual survey of our of um our
participants and that is the theme that
comes out of every survey that we have
is I've been able to reduce the amount
of Med other medications I needed to
take but there's no National study
there's no clinical research there's
nothing to demonstrate this is the big
problem with cannabis is there because
it is still federally scheduled we don't
have the sort of gold standard studies
that we would like all right was was
there a question over here I saw a
movement
somewhere I had one but it's not on this
topic so if people still want to pursue
go ahead come back to your question if
you can is it go do you want to answer
now go I'll go all right um so I'm still
stuck on the previous side slide I had a
question the middle row um about the
unemployment compensation is that amount
a management function or is that
reimbursement to the unemployment
fund the that that amount is dictated by
the department of administrative
services so you'll see unemployment
compensation within all of our our
respective division areas so it's a
standard amount there's there's other
class lines um that are similar
different but similar like transfers to
plant and property like that's another
class line on page 9008 where we're
we're we're given a number and we put
that number in there um there's there's
also uh class uh 41 audit fund set aside
there's a prescribed rate of 01 1% that
we have to set aside for federal aits
that we um as a state pay for additional
fringe benefits that's that that's a
similar scenario where there's a
methodology that's prescribed in the
budget briefing book when we prepare
that so so that's kind of one of those
things that's sort of outside of our
control when we put this together but
but it feeds towards a larger system
administered by the department of
administrative Services thank you I kind
of thought it was something like that
and it I hadn't focused on it in
previous times so I just thought I'd get
it cleared up and thank you thank you so
we will move in out of the office of the
director and we will move to slide 16
which is an overview of our Bureau of
public health statistics and informatics
we call it bipy it's a cute name for an
incredibly important um Bureau this work
is all pursuant to RSA 126 it Ser this
group this Bureau serves as our data
Steward and our public health statistics
and informatics Center for all for
health related data it is very connected
to the other work throughout the
department um on our Enterprise
functions but in particular within
Public Health their role is really
around the population Health measures
and then many many many of the systems
that we have that are often tied to
Federal programs for managing individual
types of um conditions or systems that
need to function within Public Health we
provide um data stewardship and
governance for all of those data sets
ensuring alignment with our department
government governance and management
strategies we strongly focus on privacy
as representative Edwards knows he sits
on our our Vital Records privacy board
or at least has sat on that which we
work with co- facilitate with the um
Department of uh Secretary of State
Division of Vital Records it also um
focuses so there's the data component as
well as the informatics component it
maintains our integration and our
reporting system so again how we get
reports into our laboratory from
Healthcare Providers or reports around
infectious diseases syndromic
surveillance um and supports our in
promotes our
interoperability this is an area where
we received an a number of additional
federal funds over the pandemic as you
can imagine and it was they were really
focused on data modernization not only
to address the tens thousand hundreds of
thousands pieces of data that came to us
over the pandemic but it allowed us to
strengthen A system that was beginning
to be Antiquated at that time so there
were funds over time being used in this
area and um as representative ards
pointed out oftentimes those were
contracts with entities um to help us do
that technical work because we cannot
hire for those within the in the state
often because we just can't find the
tech technical expertise to do that work
we have over 30 different Data Systems
we have reduced this number so pointing
towards efficiency over time and with
those Federal Investments we have
started to reduce the number of systems
and consolidate where possible and
really move to a sales a consistent
Salesforce platform we work very closely
with the Department of um information
technology to do all of that work so if
you slide into ex uh to slide 17 you can
start seeing some of the budget overview
um bipy has about five accounting units
um because some of these are less than a
million dollars they're not in your
budget book so when you look at this
seat and you see the na that highlights
for you that it's a smaller often grant
that doesn't um so it doesn't raise to
the level to be in your budget briefing
book so I'll go through start on slide
17 a few of those items so we start with
our informatics and health statistics
this is a mixed bag of funds um we have
about 1.3 million in federal about
622 in um in general funds here and this
is the uh provide some of the backbone
work to um to bipy again establishing
and maintaining that integration
Electronic Reporting we can move down
into the payral risk factor survey
that's a Federal grant relatively small
um and that funds A CDC survey that asks
people about their Health uh their
health their and their experience
getting healthc care um it's a great
survey it's how we learn things like
prevalence of smoking prevalence of
overweight it comes through the
behavioral risk factor survey we have
our cancer reg yep uh Finance question
on uh the informatics and health stati
statistics you're mentioning
pharmaceutical rebates yes that that
shows up somewhere as an other Revenue
line I believe and that his historically
this line is often undercounted or
underestimated on the order of like 10
million or more and because of our
budget situation if that's the case I
think we need to we need to identify the
full a full true estimate on what we're
going to get from rebates I I I believe
you're referring to the Medicaid
pharmaceutical rebates oh okay which are
which are higher and and we did have we
did have a
one-time um fiscal item that came
through to accept additional uh Federal
rebate that went back I I I think almost
a decade because of a a a programming uh
detail that had to be corrected where we
were able to claim those funds but that
was a onetime situation that the fiscal
committee saw I think this past November
maybe okay so you just corrected me that
this Ryan White pharmaceutical rebates
program it is very specific to Public
Health that is around HIV and AIDS
medication okay and so the amount so
these rebates are probably relatively
small compared to the certainly compared
to Medicaid yes all right thank you
thank you so we have our informatics and
health statistics our our burus our
behavioral risk factor survey we have
our cancer registry budgeted within our
Bureau of population of um health
statistics and informatics um that has
this is one of those where there is a
the those General funds are a
maintenance of effort um that match to
the federal funds that is our our
Statewide um cancer surveillance system
that tells us about Cancer Care and
cancer experiences in the state um here
on 1628 the strengthening Public Health
infrastructure sometimes you hear us
refer to this as fig
phig um the public health infrastructure
Grant fig um this is one of those places
that this is a newer um Federal grant
Federal resource that came to us as a
result of CO as a result of covid quite
frankly ending it came towards the end
of the pandemic it's designed um we we
have a it's designed to support the
workforce in general there's a
technology and an informatics component
which is why it's here in our informatic
section but it also supports individuals
in other other areas throughout the
division of Public Health Services
um you will notice in this one just in
case you want to ask a question there's
a little bit extra money budgeted if you
go to the budget briefing book or in the
budget but the budget briefing book
shows that um the governor's budget
shows a higher amount in state fiscal
year 26 it's not because we've received
additional funding it's really that we
haven't spent the previous year's
funding and the funding is moving
forward just because of when the funding
came to us and when we were able to get
contracts and and staff um support staff
hired into those roles so it's not that
there's really necessarily an increase
we're just budgeting it in that year
appropriately and and none of that's
General funds no nope nope and then we
have ybs and I know that that's um
that's the youth risk behavioral survey
we've had lots of conversations and
policies around that that is the uh
completely voluntary and Anonymous
survey that is done within high schools
families can opt out of that um schools
can opt out of this but this is the data
where we learn things like how many kids
are using tobacco products or vaping or
what their experience is in in receiving
health care that comes from the youth
risk behavior so if we change that to an
optin instead of an opt out and we
reduced participation by about
50% uh wouldn't that be a a sufficient
proxy for the county information we need
and if we coupled that with what we're
seeing in Vermont and Maine that in the
aggregate we would be we would make no
different policy decisions based on
having 100% of the data versus 50% I I'm
not sure that that's true so this is one
of these highly designed methodological
studies where we try and make sure that
it is representative of the entire not
only the entire State of New Hampshire
but each region so the schools that
participate in this program participate
so that they can understand what's
happening in their schools and in their
communities and without having the
appropriate weights and the appropriate
distribution around the state we can't
say that anymore we might be able to say
x% of New Hampshire kids do this we
certainly wouldn't be able to say x% of
kids in kowas County are experiencing
something different than the kids in
Hillsboro County and so that's a
methodological
questional examples differential
examples between different schools that
have implemented different policies that
are meant to respond to their school
results 100% so the schools and the
regions use this to whether or focus on
bullying whether to focus on sexual
assault whether the experience of sexual
assault whether to focus on Tobacco
whether to work focus on substance use
that's what those communities do with
this data it's incredibly important to
them oftentimes you'll see them come out
this is often as you know a a policy
question that we talk about in the
education committee and um because this
is anonymous it is different than other
places where we gather permission we we
have an opt out on this because it is
anonymous no child's name is attached to
this it is not an individual's um it is
reflective of their experience but it is
different than say our immunization
system where it's really about an
individual's Health Care is is it is it
truly fully Anonymous I I I've had
people tell me that if somebody some
kids survey comes in saying that they
are thinking about suicide that there is
a way to dig into the data to find out
who that individual student I do not
believe you can do that you may know
that that child is considering aside
because of other behaviors that that
child expresses but the data doesn't
there is no place where there is a name
on this survey I I know that but because
uh if you put enough personal data
together you can retroactively figure
out who the individual I am not aware
that we have ever been able to do that
okay that's that's important and and
you've got people who are pretty smart
saying that it's not fully Anonymous
correct and we're happy to have those
conversations with them all right
representative
priest thank you Mr chairman and uh back
on page 17 on each of these activity
accounting units do you have numbers of
clients that you
serviced uh for the last in fiscal year
24 sure so in some of those places I
mean some of these um so if I think
about informatics and health statistics
that's really infrastructure work you
know so that's not a direct service yeah
that's an exception yes but our cancer
registry we certainly can tell you the
number of individuals that are within
our cancer registry and how we use that
similarly Public Health infrastructure
again that's a more of a Workforce
situation y RBS we can tell you the
number of Youth that participated and
and both of these uh surveillance
surveys
um once they're collected what do you do
with them and do you pass them on to
other agencies for sure so are you
talking about collect the actual
information or the okay so these are
done electronically so we don't have a
stack of you know individual papers with
anybody's name on them or anything so
that's they're built into webbased
systems um in both of the cases of um
burus the behavioral risk factor survey
which is adults and the youth um risk
behavior survey which is youth um the
data um anonymized completely anonymized
is um cleaned and looked at by CDC they
have a role in analyzing that data and
then we analyze that data here we put
that data very publicly and
transparently on our wisdom dashboard so
our data portal New Hampshire if you
want to the best way to find that is to
Google New Hampshire data portal or DHHS
data portal so all of that information
is available to everyone in in the state
and then a many um different advocacy
organizations and public health and
schools use the data to really figure
out what they're going to focus on
especially when you're talking about ybs
that's really focused the schools get
their own data and how often do you do
this once the ybs is done every other
year so we are currently doing it right
now we're in 2025 we do it on odd years
um burus I believe is done every year
okay represented Daniels thank
you thank you on this voluntary program
what what is your participation rate so
I can get um you know I we can come back
to you with the exact number I don't
have that off the top of my mind head
but the way it sort of functions is that
the school decide first of all the
school decides that whether or not it's
GNA they're going to participate that's
a local decision made by school boards
and and School administration so that
that sort of starts that and then
there's a very um specific way in which
the schools if they choose to
participate make the the survey
available to parents and then there is
an opt out process and I would have to
um ask the com ask our folks here and we
can probably get that to you by lunch
how what the number is for opting out of
that okay so you're you're you're you're
saying that before the opt out decision
is made yes that they see every question
that's in the survey it is available you
know to the degree which all of us as
busy parents read those things I don't
know but it is made available
electronically for everyone and and so
and because this is such a
valuable source of information and the
purposes of it are so good why wouldn't
a simple little marketing effort to
parents convince them that they ought to
go ahead and opt in instead of doing an
opt out which you know I believe is
truly unethical after Decades of
experience in corporate privacy opt out
is an unethical way to gather personal
data so I I appreciate this and this is
a place that I know that we often have
had a disagreement especially around
this because it's a completely Anonymous
survey so that there is no way to tie
that back to an individual um I think
you know I will frame it this way I I
don't know how many of you had high
school kids but and how many of you got
a piece of paper that was stuck in the
bottom of a backpack to try and get and
the logistics for the school district to
manage that certainly would suggest that
we would have far less participation
because simply managing that is is
complicated and it would be on the back
of the school district to manage so we
don't really know that that an effective
marketing program aimed at parents to
get them to opt in we have we have the
experience of other states that have
tried that and they've seen rapid
declines in participation but we're
better all right I'll that that's enough
enough of the public meeting thank
you representative Daniels uh understand
that schools can opt out parents can opt
out uh can student opt out 100% they can
stop they they can just choose not to
take it they could answer three
questions and sit back and not do it
anymore no one is making anyone do this
survey do we actively Market that they
can opt out or is it sort of just
embedded in the process that they go
with the flow and they don't even
realize what they're doing that is
managed at the school district level but
that is part of the directions that
we've given them and you know again I
think for those of you who've had
teenagers they know when they can
stop all
right I've I've had two
yes okay so slide
18 um this just gives you again some
highlights a lot a lot of these you'll
see this theme throughout the
presentation these are just numbers
they're you know really for um just to
give you a sense of the volume of some
of the work you know one of the roles of
the Bureau of population Health Services
is to receive data requests you you know
whether it is a right to no request or
um some other you know media Outlet or
uh some other entity we do data requests
all the time we do that very carefully
that's where our stewardship of the data
comes in and making sure that we're not
giving away um identifiable information
inappropriately um we have onboarding
we've done this thing called electronic
case reporting which is really helpful
to healthc care providers so that we've
gone from uh when you know at the
beginning of covid we were literally
getting fax machine responses to like
incidences of covid we've gone to an
electronic case reporting that's what
the re the federal resources have
enabled us to do and then we manage
about 587 data visualizations on that
New Hampshire data portal it's a if you
love looking at charts and tables you
can get lost in it for you know a day
looking at all of the health outcomes in
the state of New
Hampshire so um as you go into slide 19
this is what that those data portal
looks like um just are screenshots of
what you can do it's very informative
you know we are able to cut that data in
many different ways by areas of the
state you know by male by female by age
there's lots of fascinating ways that
you can manipulate that data that
doesn't identify individuals but really
helps us understand the health um status
of New Hampshire residents um and then
again we can only do that through the
data integration and the data
modernization that we work so lots of
people much smarter than me make all
these things happen um I just been
benefit by able being able to look at
all of the incredible reports that
happen from everything from heart
disease to opioid use to maternal
mortality and on and
on so we can now move into our Bureau of
Public Health protection
bphp um that is on slide 20 um here this
is where we do that important work that
protects you know from foodborn illness
radiological Health lead poisoning all
of that is within our our Bureau of
Public Health protection um you know my
fun my you know I not only do I love
data I also love history you'll remember
from my presentation a couple of weeks
ago this is the original work in the
1880s that the Department of Health was
assigned to do which was to ensure that
our food and our milk was safe that was
the original authorization of the
Department of Health so we have been
doing this work for well over a century
um keeping New Hampshire individuals um
free from adulterations and some of
those those things as we move into slide
21 we jump into this budget they have
seven accounting units in here um we
start with food protection um there's
about 1.8 million 75% of that is General
funds and 25% of that is other funds
there is no this is not a self-funded
program the um General those licensing
fees and others come into the program
they can keep a portion of it but the
rest of it goes into the general fund
and then the general fund um supports
the program so it's not a self-funded
program it works with food
establishments grocery stores
restaurants as well as dairies other
entities including schools um and food
protection we've done about 4,000 food
inspections a
year we um have our radiological Health
fees this is where this is a program
that is self-funded through those
licensing and registration fees um there
are over 5,000 machines as we noted
x-rays MRIs and some industrial machines
um that can impact human health we make
sure that they're running appropriately
and we've got the physicists to do that
work um we then also these other are
smaller um accounts in bring your
attention to the lead poisoning
prevention fund this is an account that
has other phones again other funds some
licensing some fees it's very small um
but we've used it most recently for
supporting a data system
we go into slide 22 um as I look around
great um we have more lead funding in
here we have um the lead remediation
program so we have some funds from the
Department of Environmental Services
that we take some groundwater trust
money from Dees get sent over to um
public health and we are working in
Partnership to support um Child Care
Facilities to make sure that they don't
have uh that they can reduce the lead in
their drinking water
water primarily from the hardware from
the pipes and the faucets so we have
some resources that we're able to
provide child care providers to make
sure that uh their water is
safe go ahead yeah just a quick question
so and all this stuff I don't see any
anything related to asbest is that no
longer we do not um that is done within
the divis the Department of
Environmental Services
not
DHHS and what's the reason for I mean
lead is handled here but as best this is
handled someplace El yes it just the way
the pie is broken up I mean it asbestos
is in Dees that's all you know there was
a time again if I go on my history uh
Soap Box there were times between
there's some you know you cut the pie
differently between public health and
environmental services we have lead they
have asbest okay thank you yep thank you
we do work closely with them you know
just importantly they're the
environmental services and public health
are actually in the same building up on
Hazen drive so there's a lot of
crossover and a lot of partnership as we
do some investigations but the
authorities just sit within two
different
departments thank
you super so the lead prevention fund um
the
7964 this is federal funds and general
funds this is a um an accounting unit
where we actually have lots of different
sources of revenue in there we have some
CDC funds we have funds from the
Environmental Protection Association we
use some of those funds that we talked
about earlier those fig those um Public
Health infrastructure Grant funds and
then we use something called the
preventative Services block grant which
is a uh a flexible fund that we'll get
to at the end of the presentation it's
budgeted in another part of the um of
the division but this this work in lead
prevention under
7964 the CDC C funds pay for
surveillance um ensuring that we reduce
the rates of of kids with high blood
blood levels um our general funds
generally are used for nurses and nurse
case management so we have when we have
a child that has an elevated blood level
we have a nurse on we have a couple
nurses on board that work with them to
make sure that those kids get the care
that they need and the followup they
need the Fig that infrastructure um
Grant pays for some licensing folks and
our gramp pays for legal support to the
program so should I have a a a practical
question about the lead testing we the
state has been making a lot of over
efforts to reduce environmental lead
okay I understand that fundamentally
though we still have an issue if a child
comes in with elevated lead we we don't
really understand how they became um I I
want to say infected but that's not the
right word how they became
uh how the lead got there poisoned that
would work is poisoned so we don't know
the source of their being poisoned but
while we're trying to reduce the
environmental lead is there is there
something that am I just wrong can can
we actually identify the sources of
poisoning per child and and remediate
those more directly so we have enough
evidence so I I understand that there
are is always some question about that
but we have enough evence evidence and
experience over time that when a child
lives in a house that has um unstable
lead so that there's lead chipping
peeling lead dust in that home from lead
paint you know as we all know lead paint
was banned in 1970 but New Hampshire has
some of the oldest housing stock in the
country so we got a lot of old houses
mine being one of them you know uh this
is an area I feel personally very strong
about my own child had elevated lead as
a child as as a 2-year-old because we
were doing repairs to my 1920s house
were repairing it there was dust
everywhere it was before that there the
um the uh the uh the construction
workers need to be licensed they were
acting in an unsafe way there was dust
everywhere and my 2-year-old was
poisoned she was a thumb sucker there
was dust in the house she put her hand
down she put her thumb in her mouth she
put her hand down she put her thumb in
her mouth my older child who was just
two years older had zero in her system
because she was not putting her hand
down putting her thumb in her mouth so
what we know is that when we can tie it
back to something like that and then we
remediate that lead in the home the
incidence of lead in that child's blood
goes down and if it doesn't go down we
need to know to look somewhere else but
by far the housing stock in the lead
paint is the primary driver there are
other issues there's lead toys from
China you know there are other things
that could possibly be the case but in
New Hampshire we've seen over and over
again if you remediate the lead paint in
the house the the lead in the child that
has been poisoned they're um the percent
of blood lead in their uh percent of
lead in their blood goes down so can I
do an exact you know isotope to isotope
and prove that maybe not but that
experience tells us something helped and
and fixing the house
helped so I guess that's the difference
between public health and individual
health you're you're taking care of an
aggregate public problem and and it
still leaves open the fact that if we
have an individual patient it's hard to
identify exactly how they got poison
yeah absolutely but I know as a parent
of a child that had elevated blood when
we fixed it the BL blood Le level went
down and that was enough for me again my
as a homeowner um I did that on my own
the um licensing that we do and the
inspecting and when we put orders on
homes that's for landlords who are
renting and making money off that
property they have a different
responsibility than as an individual
it's actually something where we've
really grown over the past couple years
we've used additional resources to be
able to reach out to those homeowners
because it used to be that the
homeowners were sort of out on their own
to deal with it um and so we the this
general court has been very supportive
of making sure that we have support not
only for the landlord we you know the
landlords have to do it it's their
business but also for the homeowners
that they have the support they need to
fix to do the remediation
I hope your child's okay she she's great
now she's she's an adult right she's an
adult now but it was very scary sure so
there you go that's my Soap Box on
lead represent Daniels thank you in the
budget book book on page
921 uh in uh
6712 of 548 re what are
reagents reagents that's a great
question that's for the laboratory that
is the what we use to be able to make
the test run so sometimes it's you know
the supplies that help so that to do the
testing okay thank you that's a great
question representative sewart do you
have a question your mic's on oh no
super so we'll continue to go through um
we have the environmental Public Health
tracking program that's 100% Federal
phones funds um in addition to this work
in environmental Public Health tracking
that does some data um and analysis we
also have our radon program where we
gave give out those free radon tests um
as we slide into slide 23 again high
level 28,000 lead tests 3500 radon tests
almost 4,000 inspections in the food
protection folks are very busy um our
provider you know when you think about
lead testing we've had a lot of
conversation about increasing the rates
of blood lead testing especially of of
um youth that are or kiddos that are in
Medicaid we want to make sure that we're
getting as many kids tested as possible
it's the law at age one and two so
there's some additional information on
lead on slide 24 again um about 1100
kids in New Hampshire had elevated blood
lead levels enough to impair their think
learn and concentrate um in 2023 that is
an extraordinary number to think about
that we've had there's been a lot of
media around the fact that those numbers
went up from 21 to 23 we believe part of
that is being um the reason we're seeing
more kids with elevated is because we're
doing better at screening so you know we
all knew in the story we had early on
around 21 when kids were not going to
the doctor or going for a few things we
just simply didn't screen it so those
numbers went way down but as we're
getting that screening back to where it
needs to be um we're seeing the numbers
go up that's not necessarily a great
thing we don't want more kids with BL
blood blood levels but we think it's an
artifact of the
screening so represent priest did you
have a question I'm going to go to n
vano first and then you okay thank you
very much
very very I know uh representative
Daniels raised a question on the radon
radon testing so you're not you're not
keeping track so if somebody sends back
the radon test you don't actually see or
track or keep a registry or anything I
we don't keep we certainly don't keep a
registry and I'm going to have my team
let us know what they use to evaluate
that and and the so the test comes back
positive so what's the follow-up action
on so what we've done with that is
provide some instruction to a homeowner
where you know that these are things
that should be assessed by a
professional to understand how they can
mitigate the radon in their house so
really the idea about giving the tests
out is simply to give people the tools
they need so they can manage their own
home and make sure it's safe and and
just a brief followup do you do you know
I mean I lived in other areas where Ron
tests were basically conducted when a
homeowner went to sell the house and
part of the inspection process whether I
don't I recall whether Connecticut
required that as part of the inspection
process but um why that isn't uh what
happens in New Hampshire so I'm going to
say something a little out of turn here
and I I'm I can be easily corrected by
the team my team we have not in my
memory um enacted legislation that
requires those testing it often happens
when you buy your house it sort of you
know is negotiated on but I can't I my
recollection is that we do not require
it again the team can fill me in if I'm
wrong yeah I'm just wondering about the
efficacy of the the program because I've
been you know certainly in the situation
where so house the efficacy of the
program really you know we'll get more
details for you but we're really looking
at lung cancer rates you know we know
that areas of New Hampshire just by the
granite that we're built on that are
have higher rates of lung cancer and it
comes from radon and so again a
population Health a public health
approach is to give people the tools
they need to mitigate their risks and
one of it is just knowing whether or not
they got raidon in their house and then
they they have the responsibility to
mitigate okay thank you your
representative
priest thank you Mr chairman and and
thank you uh Miss Tilly um for taking my
question um back on page uh 20 uh 4 do
you have uh figures for
24 as to the number of children that uh
has been tested with high blood levels
of lead and in their system so we have
we collect that data that data has not
yet been analyzed for 24 but we we have
it it's not been analyzed and what
measures do you have to help remediate
it so in in ter we we follow so this is
the role of the nurse case manager so we
um ensure we do two things one um we
ensure we address the environmental
causes so um we could if the the child
lives in a rented home or in we will go
out and do the inspection and we can
make sure that we can talk about what
needs to be remediated in the home and
that's part of how we address that if
the child lives um in a home owned by it
their parents we just simply Provide
support but over time we can track the
blood blood levels as they come down as
that remediation happens okay thank
you okay great um slide 25 gets to the O
I'm sorry we still have representative
Daniel oh I'm sorry thank you on page 24
the chart there that shows the
4570 people has the threshold to
determine lead poisoning changed between
2019 and
2023 I'm going to have to get back to
you on that it changed I don't remember
the date okay thank you thank you I
apologize I'm not the director of Public
Health anymore I should have had that on
the top of my
head represent torki very quickly I'm
looking at this I'm very conc ered to
see that children who are on Medicaid um
are twice as likely to have lead
poisoning 100% tied to I'm assuming
older homes lower income rents that kind
of thing um can you if we forward look
to uh the proposal for um
changing chip um that we're looking at
in the budget concerns about being able
to identify these children provide
proper treatment and get them in a safe
home do you have any is so you know I
mean we have worked very closely Public
Health has worked very closely with
Medicaid this has been a a huge um
emphasis both in the MCO contracts and
others is to increase the screening
rates for Medicaid because we know that
they dispropor those infant those kids
disproportionately live in older homes
or in rental facilities compared to the
broader population and so the insurance
is the vehicle that gets them into their
well child visits and that's where the
screening occurs right so there's no
there's 's no other possible screening
for these These are really infants SL
one and twoy olds one and two year olds
one screening at one and two is what we
do is the is the little pneumonic that
we have um so we want to make sure that
they're getting it you know historically
days before chip you would find Wick
clinics trying to you know jump in and
try and do some of the screening but the
best place to do this screening and to
manage it is within a Primary Care
Physician's office thank you for
that so so I I think Mr Litman with the
Medicaid Program routinely puts
incentives to yes get particular
behavior and it sounds like you're
implying that uh the lead testing in the
youth is a definite
incentive I I couldn't speak to what the
exact incentive is but it is prioritized
in their contract right so that's how
they get their incentive uh money I I
believe um and then um I had another
thing I wanted to say about that
oh is it possible looking at this data
that because Medicaid put such an
emphasis on this that regular
Insurance isn't keeping up and so it
isn't that necessarily that the kids
with regular Insurance have a lower
incidence of lead it just they may have
a lower incidence of being tested and
evaluated for it so we look at that I
could probably we could probably get
that data for you because we get lead
tests on every child not just Medicaid
child children or children on Medicaid
um so we can look at that differential I
do think a good driver of it is um the
substandard conditions in the housing
all right I mean that makes sense I just
want to make sure we're interpreting the
data properly because this jumps out at
you you know and we have made so you
know this is a place where we've also
made public health improvements around
things like fixing the you know uh
certifying the um the folks that do the
construction work that they now have to
work in a safe way where they didn't
when my child was poisoned we just had
you know like our contractor doing this
work and he was just out there sanding
like crazy that doesn't happen anymore
and that's in part due to the work of
this lead program all right sry thank
you um so slide 25 is radiological
Health one of again my favorite things
to talk about you'll see this is that
pie chart I was referencing early 58% of
the machines are in the dental
facilities um so you can think about
that next time you go to the dentist um
that's that's where a lot of them are
you know some even surprised around 11%
in chiropractic offices so there are
places that we I think it is important
for us to have a regulatory function to
go out there and ensure that those um
machines are safe for human health at
the end of the day one of the things
also just an interesting way that we use
this work uh the physicists who work
here is not only to do those inspections
but they're also responding to
radiological incidents in the state in
October we had a case where there was a
car accident a vehicle accident of a
vehicle that had radiological Health um
equipment in it and the car went on fire
on the road and so we deployed our team
right away First Responders came
notified us and our radiological Health
team went out right away to assure that
there was no danger to the First
Responders who were um working on that
vehicle accident so they serve not only
this function so to your point around
can you do this privately
you know you could do anything privately
but one of the things by having it built
in within public health is we can have
this emergency response function in
addition to having an objective um
standard to making sure that um all the
equipment is safe thank you all right so
we can go into the Bureau of family
health and nutrition just just to do a
quick time check um we got a lot we got
a lot right uh so are we anticipating U
we can go back after lunch or
yes I think we will have to come back
after lunch okay so yesterday we took a
a a noon recess and came back at
12:45 looks like we're going to do that
again this time great representative PR
thank you Mr chairman for uh my allowing
me to uh give a question um Miss Tilly
what about the radioactive waste that
comes from the various machines how do
you handle that so we our team helps uh
is uh there are regulations around all
of that and we ensure that they follow
those regulations to get rid of that
waste okay thank
you great so we're going to slide into
um slide 26 which is our Bureau of
family health and nutrition um this
you'll recall was one of those bureaus
that were split that is the result of a
bureau being split in half so this is
the half that is maternal and child
health and our women infant and children
nutrition program on slide 27 through 31
there are over 20 accounting units
within the Bureau of family um health
and nutrition it's part of the reason
that Bureau was split apart because
there were probably almost 40 accounting
units in the combined Bureau before and
we in order to have span of oversight of
the budget it made sense to split it up
um we we can go quickly happy to answer
any questions through here pre pregnancy
risk monitoring s um system that is uh
another one of those surveys called
prank
um and it is a survey that is funded by
the CDC um and sent to pregnant women uh
or women who have given birth and um
voluntary they can fill out that survey
and send back an anonymous survey to
help us understand their experience um
while they were pregnant and after
giving birth um our Wick food rebates so
much like pharmaceutical rebates this is
another place where we use sort of an
Innovative partnership with with uh
Corporate America we sign into a
contract to use a particular brand of
infant formula we re the the it is free
to the women and the pregnant women and
I'm not pregnant women but the women who
have an infant um it's free to the
infants um we reimburse the stores at
that rate and we get a rebate back that
we put into the food program so it's a
way that we can get more money to make
sure that we have more food for um for
pregnant women and young children up to
age five there's about $4 million
budgeted in here our MCH data linkage um
again very tiny Grant doesn't even show
up in our budget briefing book and this
just works on some of our data uh work
within maternal and child health the
maternal and child health block grant
5190 is a bigger um uh uh budgeted area
it's about 5.6 million in federal funds
3.6 million in general funds this is a
maintenance of effort the block grant
was developed back in the 80s I believe
um and so there's a maintenance of
effort of how much funds that we use to
support this work this is a lot of our
infrastructure uh for supporting all of
our efforts around um pregnant
individuals and infant
Health we go on to the next slide slide
28 we have our newborn screening we have
a question represent quick question on
the maternal and child health section
what uh constitutes qualitative
preventive you know it says increas
access to qualitative preventive what uh
quality preventative and primary care
services for children and women of
reproductive Age We fund our federally
qualified Health Centers to ensure that
they have high quality prenatal care and
um pediatric care for kids so that's
what the preventative is it has nothing
to do with preventing pregnancy or so
you'll well it may um so uh
contraception is part of is a routine
part of preventative Healthcare so
that's that could be included in here
you'll also see a little bit further
we're going to talk about family
planning which may be the place that you
ever question more about um the sexual
and reproductive Health Services right
thank you thank you um great we have a
newborn screening revolving fund this is
another you know classically New
Hampshire way that not use General funds
we charge the hospitals um for the
filter paper when every baby is born
they get a little blood spot on their
heel they also have ear their hearing
tested they also have their heart um
monitored um and we charge the hospitals
for the filter p paper we essentially
sell it back to them that pays for the
program so it pays for the monitoring of
that program it also pays for the actual
testing we have a contract with UMass in
Boston that does um the screening you
have to do the screening in an
incredibly time-sensitive way the whole
point of newborn screening is that a
baby may be born looks perfectly healthy
to all of us has no clinical signs but
actually could have some heritable
conditions that even things like
drinking formula could um cause
significant um developmental concerns or
even death so you need to do more
screening within 24
hours reprentative go ahead what would
heritable conditions that would cover
something like
TX tax is not one of the conditions that
we have we have a list of about 40ish
conditions um specific to hear what we
screen for are the things that you would
have a in a child that would look
clinically normal from just sort of eyes
and ears and a doctor looking at them
but they might have a genetic disorder
or some other develop some other
disorder that would or chromosomal
disorder that would make it that we need
to do something quickly there needs to
be an intervention why why would take
Tacs not make that uh you know what I
I'll I've got my newborn screening
specialist sitting in the audience she
can I can tell you that when I get back
after lunch and I only yeah I only asked
because we had experience with that
where we you know had a where the
developmental process and a grandchild
stopped at about two
yes and so what I can tell you about
that so these conditions are things
where something bad is going to happen
right away like immediately and that
there's actually an intervention that
can help so that sort of speaks to T why
it might be different than Tacs so these
are places where um it started with
something called PKU testing because we
knew that an an infant couldn't um metab
metabolize fat and it would impact their
brain development you know right away so
we needed to know before that baby
actually started eating in Formula or
breast milk that we needed to pursue a
different path and that so the we have a
process with a newborn screening
committee that determines which uh
conditions are in or out so we can talk
more about
it all right wick supplemental nutrition
program um we have more pardon us again
representative Daniel I'm sorry just one
one quick question on that uh do I
understand you to say that uh parents
don't have a choice is that no parents
always have a choice so they can they
can opt out of that program at any time
they're given information um early on
and they can opt out of newborn
screening okay thank you and the opt out
rate is less than 2% and and that um
that looks to the parent to be free a
free service yes right
yes thank you so Wick supplemental um
nutrition so that's the big Grant around
Wick you know we take some of those
rebate monies and sort of support what's
in the wick program um we have more
information about that on slide 32 we
serve about 12 12,000 low-income
pregnant postpartum breastfeeding women
infants and children to age five
tremendous program we're very supportive
of it um and that those funds come from
you um
USDA um now we can get to Family
Planning all right so very quick
question on on the um uh
do does do you have a program that
encourages breastfeeding or yes so
within our Wick program we strongly
encourage breastfeeding we know that
that's the choice of every individual
there's no requirement to do that but we
certainly provide the education that
breastfeeding is um a very healthy way
to support the your infants growth and
development thank
you thank you we also do that in our
maternal and child health programs like
the federally qualified Health Centers
but Wick really is the strong promoter
of um breastfeeding so in Family
Planning will you anticipate our
questions and try to just make it part
of what you're about to say sure so
Family Planning is a program funded by
title 10 we have some general funds
attached to it that are generally
matched to it um Family Planning
services are about contraception care
about screening for cancer about
screening for other chronic diseases it
does not include abortion um abortion is
not allowed under Federal funding it is
not allowed with within our state
contracts we have four providers in the
state of New Hampshire that provide
family planning Services three of them
are federally qualified Health Centers
the other one is beln not maram Capa
Community Action Program those are the
providers that we have today no abortion
is funded we have had several audits of
that work that show that we have
separation of funds um but currently we
do not have any vendors that also
provide abortion Services um that you
would know of happy to answer question
is it still the casee that the executive
Council has been exercising its contract
discretion to not provide contracts to
particular vendors that is correct the
last time that we brought this to um the
executive Council we had put out had a
um an open procurement um three
organizations that also provide abortion
Services went through the procurement
met all the met all of our contract
standards showed separation of funds the
executive Council chose not to fun chose
not to move those contracts forward do
you have a
question all right uh representative tki
thank you this might not be a question
for you but um do you have any feedback
on what that lack of executive Council
funding um not putting those contracts
through what that could mean for the
financial stability of those
organizations that provide necessary
Health Care to so many people in state
yeah unfortunately because we no longer
have a contract with them we don't get
to see their um you know audit document
or their financials anymore they've
certainly expressed in the news that it
it has an impact on them but we don't
have any uh contractual relationship
with them so we can't no thanks great um
I I would think that uh given the salary
of the CEO of the New England region and
the advertising I've seen done uh they
seem to have resources there's more than
one organization I know but I'm talking
about a pretty specific one and talking
about some other specific ones too all
right thank you all right um then we
move into an area where we do have
General funds um this is our community
collaboration line um this serves uh our
children by um promoting positive
parenting programs we H in here is our
comprehensive Family Support Services
our home visiting some newborn navig
newborn navigation kinship navigation
which is a partnership with DCF that's
for um when children are placed with a
member of their family we help support
them so that they know how to get access
to the services they need and and
support them in their parenting Journey
especially for if it's a grandparent the
second time around um and our Family
Resource Centers and our family
connection center at the um at the uh
state prisons um there's a lot more
information on slides 36 and 37 when we
get and as we get there we can dive in
if you'd like or I'm happy to answer
questions now
okay so you mentioned prisons and when I
think of Prisons I think of a program
called Choose Love Is that in here where
where is Choose Love Choose Love is in
our division of Behavioral Health all
right thank you y um similar for family
support on on slide 29 we have our home
visiting we call this the formula grant
these are funds that come from um the
federal government we have a small
amount of General funds in here um
because we had an opportunity if we
added some addition additional General
funds we would get additional federal
funds so we had a base Grant from the
federal government uh by Anum of go we
added some general funds so that we
could expand this program these are
voluntary home visiting programs this is
not DCF but it really is preventative to
dcyf they're for low-income
families thank you if I could just jump
back to the community collaboration
again you mentioned that it's 100%
General funds um what I'm looking at is
back to the difference between the
current budget and the proposed budget
where it shifted and changed and I
wonder if you could clarify that sure so
I'm going to pull that up as as I'm
doing that I can let you know that we
used to have some federal funds to
support this work and that was a
time-bound grant and so we have shifted
over time and there was an investment of
um of dollars so if you
see actually I don't see that in there
you want to take it sure so so money was
moved from the division for children
youth and families from accounting units
7215 and
7216 and the and the federal award ended
which is why you see the federal funds
zero out and the general funds increase
and I I'll let Trisha speak to the some
of the rationale for for moving the
operations from DCF to dphs sure so
thank you thank you for looking that up
faster than I did um so again we had a
Federal grant that did some work that
Grant ended that's no longer funded at
the federal level but what we did is had
this resource within um public health of
folks that really did this preventative
work and it was aligned with our overall
um programs supporting pregnant women
and again outside of the dcyf system so
there were programs like comprehensive
family support that has sort of floated
around it had been in DCF it had been in
the division of Economic Security um and
the notion was to move those programs
within public health because it really
was um sometimes we call it front door
activities this is like out in the yard
this is before you enter into Services
we want to make sure that there's
prevention and that prevention Focus
really is the best fit for public
health yeah great so if we go to I'm I'm
trying real hard to speak fast you're
you're you're doing great thank you um
so uh home visiting again just want to
say I really appreciate your testimony
because you have an attorney that comes
in and talks to us occasionally and I'm
I swear he gets paid by the word so I
really I really appreciate your brevity
thank you thank you um so we have that
home visiting formula grant again
federal funds we we got extra General
funds to be able to expand that which is
a great investment um for a relatively
short amount of money um our sued case
registry so sued sudden unexpected
infant death some of you might remember
that is SIDS from when you had kids um
which was sudden infant death syndrome
these are tragic deaths that happen
often before an infant is four months
old we have a registry where we manage
where we look at that data and try to
provide preventative um services and
embed that everywhere so that we can
prevent the number of seed deaths in the
state may quick question on that is that
yeah I uh used to be in the news a lot
with CRI you know crib deaths or however
you were describing it has that uh
contined to be I mean at about the same
historic level so the the rates have
come down and and this is a place where
it's hard you know sometimes when you
Trend that over time it's hard to C
figure out what was counted 20 years ago
to what's counted today um we spend a
lot of time working with our office of
chief medical examiner who examines all
of these deaths to understand things
like how that baby was sleeping and the
conditions so as we all probably know
we've moved to this back to sleep you
know where you put babies in cribs
nothing else in it no bed you know
blankets or fluffy toys those are that's
really come from the data from not only
New Hampshire's seid case registry but
around the country of understanding what
are the contributing factors to seid and
so it's a a population Health um
promotion as well as doing the
individual education to you know all our
moms dads and grandparents about why
it's so important to have babies
sleeping on their back back not to be
close uh co-sleeping and to make sure
that you limit the number of soft U
materials around them you have go ahead
represent PRI thank you Mr chairman uh
do you offer or does another department
offer like
post um
squid bement bereavement for the parents
because I know this is has been a very
um yeah it it is devastating so we
connect them with the services that are
bement services that are available to
them okay thank you thank you it it's
devastating it is every parent worst
nightmare um we go back to some Wick
money
oh representating walner on the home
visiting is that contracted out so that
you contract with agencies yes in the
community who do the visiting yes so we
contract with names that you would
recall places like Waypoint places like
Family Resource Centers there's a couple
of um vnas that continue to do home
visiting those sorts of agencies yep um
Wick infrastructure money this is really
the money that's given to us for USDA to
manage our Data Systems we have our
poison control again a tiny amount of
money doesn't even show up in the um
budget briefing book but the Poison
Control Center we contract with Maine
Medical Center um they handle about
10,000 calls a year about poisonings um
and we get a little bit of money from
the Department of Safety for that as
well um we'll go to slide 30 we have
early hearing detection and intervention
like newborn screening we've learned you
know 20 plus years ago that it's really
important to screen infants um when
they're born for hearing because that's
when you can start doing interventions
right away to ensure that there's
language development and so parents we
do the the hospitals do the hearing
screening parents determine what the
best path for that would be in terms of
um having that hearing further identif
we the screening happens in the
hospitals then there's further followup
and then they can determine whether or
not that infant might need a c CER or if
they want to pursue sign language only
for a child that's profoundly deaf um I
just want to note that the next several
of these are 100% funded and so small
that they're not uh they're not even in
the budget vook right so so I see all
100% funding I'll the rest are all
little I'll let the members skim
yeah Mo on unless there are
questions representative
priest yes I just have a question on the
last accounting unit on page 31 yes
could you just spell what that is it is
the alliance allance for innovation in
Alliance for Innovation maternal Health
it's write down there Innovation on
maternal health safety bundles for
substance use and peretto mental health
so we work with Dartmouth
um to work with all the hospitals to
figure out how we can best support um
both mom and baby when there has been
substance use thank
you great um slides 32 um 33 and 34 give
you some further detail around both our
Wick nutrition program in particular
Wick Farmers Market um our newborn
screening program again um you can take
a look at some of that data that we
captured over 90% of our infants have
received newborn hearing screen we're
very proud of that um and then as you
look at some of the numbers we have over
7,000 families um our Family Resource
Centers have supported over 7,000
families and there have been over 5,000
home visits um we've got additional
information there on Healthy Families
America on slide 35 that's a great quote
if you're just Bor of listening to me
talk and you want to read something else
that's a great quote from one of our
families about the importance of that
program to her um as we get into slide
36 um this may come a little bit closer
to the question that you were asking
representative Edwards yesterday around
um how we use tanif and other funds to
support two parent programs this child
and Family Services um you can see on
the map where we have those Services
located and where they serve families
all around the the country I me all
around the state um and we began to look
at your two parent program from n
Nebraska and we noticed some
similarities to what we do now and then
some differences that we could think
about incorporating as as we move
forward so a lot of the S similarities
that um we saw to that program were
promotion Improvement of healthy
relationships and co-parenting our
Family Resource Centers Provide support
groups and opportunities for parents to
engage in those social connections our
child and Family Services support home
visitors partner to identify goals for
themselves which could be things from
plan future pregnancies how they
continue their own education finding and
maintaining their employment and
household management and co-parenting
support which I think is part of those
really important there's a lot of
promotion of economic stability again
because we use tanif money we put
together a couple of different sources
of funds but tanif is in here and so the
Family Resource Centers offer budgeting
classes tax prep questiones connection
to benefits like like uh Medicaid and
the Child and Family Services child and
Family Support um cfss um also do the
similar work around you know household
management and co-parenting some of the
differences that we've had is that there
are Family Resource Centers that have
developed support support groups and
father- Le engagement what we've seen um
most of our father level engagement has
come out of DCF there's a great fathers
group that comes there there's probably
an opportunity for us to learn about
that a little bit more in public health
and maybe apply some of that to um a
more population based as opposed to the
father engagement Group which is really
around families that have entered into
the child welfare
system thank thank you for mentioning
that you guys are digging into the
Nebraska program I just I just want to
contextualize that for you a little bit
and so that nobody misinterprets what
I'm what I'm trying to do here in in the
past couple budget Cycles uh there's not
been a program that's been specifically
aimed at assisting two parent families
at least none that have been presented
to to us and in order to stimulate some
conversation within the department I
knew that Nebraska had one that they
specifically intended for that purpose
and so I wanted to use it to to prime
the pump sort of speak to get you all
talking and thinking in no way am I
saying we should emulate that or do that
I'm just saying here's a suggestion by
another state yeah absolutely and I I
think it's fair and I think that because
we have flexibility in some of these
programs they really can be dynamic and
address needs as um as we as the state
want to work across all of our divisions
to meet the multiple needs you know
around economic support around public
health promotion and prevention and I I
think there's some value in digging in a
little more all right thank you uh
representative tki thank you um thank
you I probably should have thought of
this yesterday but I didn't um when we
talk about the two parent family I think
it was number four on the tanif list
yesterday um are we necessarily talking
about a marriage certificate between two
people are we talking about could we be
two divorced parents who have a healthy
relationship and are parenting qu
jointly maybe same-sex family uh
parenting couple do we have those
non-traditional parents that are
included in this so I I'm going to go
out on a limb here because I am not a
tan of expert there is some Antiquated
language in TANF around marriage and
unwit so so an unwed so I can't speak
much more than that I know that that's
old Antiquated language that's built
into the system I can tell you when
we're talking about public health
families Define who they are and so
that's that's what we're trying to
support and we all know that two healthy
caring um caretakers is it makes life a
little bit easier than one we again
families Define who's who's their family
I think the statistics are overwhelming
right that two parent families
regardless of who making up the parents
provide for a much more stable better
economic environment for the kids yeah
and I'm agnostic on you know I think
we're agnostic of whether or not there's
a wedding certificate at the end of the
day from a public health perspective I I
I I couldn't agree more you're bound by
the rags but um but I I I think going
from no programs aimed at it to some
programs even if the programs are
focused on traditional marriage and not
a a more current version of it I think
that is still a step
forward I guess I also just had the
clarification of there's a number of
parents who are divorced who are in
healthy families and I'm just hoping
that they also could receive some of
that support but thank you for that
absolutely again families Define whose
family um have representative Daniels
great thank you thank you on that page
what does it mean when it says engage 2
225 uh
or 228
fathers um what page are we on
uh 37 37 so
engaged 228
fathers okay I'm oh I think that that's
specifically that there was a father
fatherhood engagement activity so at the
you know so each of these programs may
have done like a father's group or
something so I I interpret that as it
was a very specific
father focused activity we can get more
information for you okay I ju I didn't
know what it mean meant first of all but
then do you have one for mothers too
well I so I think this is one of the
places where you're sort of the default
historically and societally then when we
look at you know serving 1500 families
many of us think that's a mother and a
child and perhaps someone else in the
household as well again whoever they def
they um Define as their family to me as
I understand that number this was
something very specific for people who
identify as Fathers as opposed to a
caretaker but we can get more
information
great so we will move in um it's 10
minutes to
12 um I could start with the Bureau of
infectious disease or we
could I I think we're g to let
representative priest ask his question
and then I I want to summarize and let
us get off to lunch uh representative
PRI you have a question I do and thank
you for acknowledging me and thank you
Miss Tilly uh back on page
37 do you have any past numbers that
have shown your progress in these areas
so we Trend some of this data over time
and we can probably make that available
to you that would be great thank you the
I will caveat that is these programs
have been very Flex so there may be some
things that are not comparable from one
year to another but you can ask direct
that so we can okay that would be very
helpful thank you great thank you so so
I think I think we're going to land at
the beginning of Bureau of Infectious
Disease Control as we go into recess and
I I just want to uh uh thank you for
stepping in for uh Ian Ian watts is that
his name um and uh do doing just a a
fantastic job I I think you're one of
the most impressive people in state
government and we disagree periodically
but I just want you to know I respect
what you do thank you very much you bet
so we're at recess until
12:45 thank you Nan thank
you oh that's what it's called yes
not
all so I just wanted to relay that to
you and does
every
e
e e
okay it's uh it's 12:46 we're coming uh
back in division three um from a recess
uh in the break I uh got a question from
the public um uh commissioner uh Tilly
uh would would you tell us about the
interner relationship
uh and coordination between um the lead
testing that public health is doing and
the lead testing that Dees is doing and
how we make sure that there are not
redundancies and there's not wasted
opportunities to share
information thank you for the
opportunity thanks um so I think
specifically you are asking not about
the lead program in general but specific
to the funds that have come from the
Department of Environmental Services to
to do some of that lead abatement and Le
lead work in the in the community so as
I noted we work closely with the
division the Department of Environmental
Services they have transferred some of
their groundwater trust money to us to
work with child care they on the other
hand are working with schools doing a
similar effort to get the lead out of
the faucets and the hardware in school
systems to make sure that water in the
schools are safe so they have schools we
have child care and the reason for that
division of labor is in part because the
department has a licensing
um relationship with the child care as
opposed to we we don't necessarily have
a a relationship with the individual
schools so they maintain the school
piece and then they partnered with us to
take on the child care and if you think
about this larger you know I can expand
a little bit to the question earlier
around like why asbest in Dees and why
Leed in in um public health and in part
it's about the health impact so with
lead it's really an urgent need to
address um children's development so
that's really where the impact of lead
is most great is on childhood brain
development and so we do the nurse case
management and followup so it's sort of
the onew punch of the environmental side
of getting rid of the exposure and then
doing the follow-up as opposed to
something like asbest which really is
you know the health impacts you don't
see right away it's hard to tie it back
and we don't do the sort of nurse case
management for adults in the same way
that we would for kids when we're really
trying to ensure that they've got the
optimal development um so that they can
th in
school thank you you're welcome and then
with that I think uh represent Daniels
just a quick question on the program get
the lead out whose program is
that I don't know the answer to that
that may be something that we partner on
but I you know what I've been a little
separated from it we'll find out for you
thank you thank you I do have before I
dive in I've got a couple of um answers
to questions that have come in from the
phenomenal team that is behind me again
I apologize cuz I'm pinch hitting and I
don't have everything off the top of my
head um but there were a couple
questions one was around um yrbs and
there was a question around school
participation and so in 20 there are
about um 75 schools out of 82 schools
have committed to participate this year
so 2025 there's 91% and those are high
schools we only do the yrbs in high
schools um I thought some of it's eth
grade it's eth grade high schools no
other some schools opt and do it outside
of the state you know but for the state
run program we only do the high school
thank you grade N9 to 9 through 12 so
that's one answer for you right there
and then on the father question um so of
the 228 fathers that you had asked about
they either enrolled as the primary
parent or as a co-parent with the home
visitor but it's likely that they were
it was a father headed household and
that they were participating in that way
so um there you go and I just hot off
the presses um uh New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services has
to get the let out program and we
partner for the child care facilities so
those are all my quick answers for you
before we dive into what's coming next
okay thanks um so we are on slide 30 oh
okay um we are on slide 38 we're going
to be talking about our Bureau of
Infectious Disease Control so bck we
call it um brings together
epidemiologists Public Health nurses
data analysts and others to identify
investigate and prevent infectious
disease and that crosses the board from
foodborn disease arboviral which
typically in this environment we think
about as mosquito born disease tick born
disease healthc care acquired infections
and vaccine preventable disease so
that's a pretty broad span a lot of
times certainly in the days of covid
used to think you know I think many of
us thought really covid only those
respiratory diseases but bick's work
really is much more crosscutting than
that it plays up Pol additionally um
bidic plays a pretty important role in
our emergency response from outbreaks
again we all hurt lived through that
with covid but right now where we're
focused on many of those outbreaks are
things that you hear about in the news
things like measles things like
tuberculosis things like Legionella and
then ultimately we provide we partner
with our Healthcare Providers and
private sectors to ensure that everybody
gets the appropriate immunizations for
them and that that is both the school
requ the immunizations required for
school entry and then the immunizations
that are not required for anything but
are just good ideas for people that have
particular conditions so whether you're
talking about a flu vaccine that is not
required for kids or adults that's
really important especially as we've
seen this year as those Hospital rates
have gone up really high um for people
entering the hospital from flu Rel
illnesses or complications so let's dig
into slide 39 here we get into some of
the um accounting units um we start off
with Ryan White which is the part B
which is the um our program that
provides accessible um uh medication and
care for people with HIV and um AIDS um
we work with people that are up to 500%
of the federal poverty uh level or lower
to ensure sure that they have um HIV and
AIDS drug assistant those drugs are
famously expensive and this is where we
work with the pharmaceutical companies
to also get rebates and we are able to
incorporate those rebates into the
program as well so I haven't seen this
this data in a while that I can recall
but uh do you happen to know uh how many
HIV positive patients we have identified
in the state and and since you just
mentioned the expense of the
pharmaceutical what what what what's the
average uh cost of a Year's treatment
these days I certainly can't answer the
second question and I'm I'm pretty far
removed from that and our numbers are
fairly small we're among the smallest
proportion of um people living with AIDS
or people living with HIV in the country
um I've got folks behind me right now
who will be pulling that data up off the
top of their head but it's a relatively
small number but it's it's expensive for
those people who are there right um the
the second funding source that doesn't
know again it's other funds not General
funds um but just in case you're
wondering this Boston EMA part A the
city of Boston receives federal funds
for their um uh their uh metropolitan
area I don't I think it's extended
metropolitan area but I could be wrong
on what the E stands for and part of
their metropolitan area includes County
Hillsboro Rockingham and straford
counties so Boston gives us the funds
that they have for their metropolitan
area to serve the people of new
Hampshire um and again finally you have
here the the rebate numbers as are the
the funding source for the rebates so
that leads us into um I know to 5170
which is the large one of the large
Disease Control um Aus and in that we
are tracking more than 8,000 reports of
infectious disease and more than 300
outbreaks a year um and those outbreaks
can include anything from flu in a
nursing home to measels in the Upper
Valley so these are busy folks getting
lots of data in lots of reports that
they're managing and managing those
outbreaks in congregate settings um that
also includes in some of those um
outbreaks um representative Mooney has a
question but I also want to ask you in
here are we seeing any upticks in um
diseases like um Hepatitis B um that are
often associated with um immigr
ation I don't think that we have seen an
uptick necessarily in Hepatitis B um
again I can be corrected on that what I
can say is that with hepatitis A B and C
are have all been historically on have
been on the rise right now for lots of
different reasons and there are some you
know but we haven't seen anything
specifically tied that I'm aware of to
um a new American or an immigrant
population all right um and there was a
second one I don't remember which
disease is associated with um
potentially with the immigration
population but but just generally we're
not seeing an uptick in any not not in
any significant way that I'm aware of
thank you representative Mooney thank
you Mr chairman thank you for being here
a constituent once contacted me and was
concerned about a headlice breakout at a
school they wanted to know who to talk
to naturally on their behalf I contacted
DHHS and to surprise was told no not us
you contact the Department of Education
so my question to you is why and are
there any other such uh contagious type
conditions that are also handled by
other departments thank you so thank you
that's a lice is you know I think I you
start itching just thinking about it
right there um so it is correct we do
not handle um headlights uh outbreaks or
anything mainly because there isn't a
significant risk to human health it is
annoying it is not something we want in
our you know among in our children or
ourselves but there's not a real
infectious disease risk associated with
headli and so typically the Department
of Education School nurses handle that
on their own thank
you represent Tori that just brings me
to something else but what about bed
bugs do you guys deal with that or is
that where does that fall so um in in um
we do address bed bugs to a smaller
degree in our health officer liaison
roles so often that is HP that is dealt
with at the local level with our local
Health officers and so we work with our
health officers to provide them the
training that they need but it's
addressed at at the local level not at
the state level thank you are is is
there anything in the health officer
budget that is in your public health
section so we have a little bit that was
actually back in our Bureau of Public
Health protection for the most part it's
embedded there we have one fulltime
position that is a liaison to the health
officers and so we just provide them
with support and then we utilize the
entire team at Public Health to provide
the specific information that they might
need in their role the health officers
do a lot of environmental work around Su
septic and sewer and um have different
roles in each Community again a health
officer and a teeny tiny um rural town
is going to look very different than the
health officer at Manchester so we
provide some support and we provide
training for the most part all right
thank you great thank you so we can go
into slide um 40 um we have um we can
dive into the mosquito control fund just
so you know that this is a very small
amount of money that we set aside in
case there is a declared emergency
around a mosquito born illness we don't
typically use this is a sort of money
that's just um put in in reserve in case
of emergency it's fairly small um 5177
we're going to talk a little bit more on
slide 43 about that um but this is the
funding for um that we received from the
New Hampshire vaccine Association to
help ensure universal access to
Childhood vaccines that's we're going to
um so so you know there's a bill that's
talking about um eliminating the New
Hampshire vaccine association yes um and
as I understand the the two key
arguments one is that this is a great
value ad in terms of being able to uh
collect money from the vaccine
manufacturers and to effectively reduce
prices for our consumers um the the
there are some concern that by having
the state in a position to um I'm just
going to air quote profit off of of
these rebates that there's a built-in
incentive to put more vaccines on the
registry so that there's more control
and more money so those are kind of the
two positions I've heard what what are
your thoughts so thank you so if I could
just sort of correct the record a little
bit on that the way that the New
Hampshire vaccine Association works is
that it is an independent organization
it is set up in statute and it um sets
assessment rates from the commercial
payers and so it sets an assessment and
ensures that we have um essentially bulk
purchasing for insurance we they collect
the funds the New Hampshire vaccine
Association collects the funds from the
commercial prayers they then transfer
the funds to the state and that allows
DHHS to buy immunizations at a cheaper
rate through the CDC so it is a
financing mechanism that allow that does
two things it um allows larger bulk P
purchasing which is actually a costs
saver to the carriers which is important
and then secondly it also ensures that
the providers by us managing buying the
those vaccines in bulk again childhood
vaccines buying those in bulk it makes
it is a savings to the health care
providers that don't have to negotiate
with each of their carriers to figure
out which and which vaccines they have
when they're going to have it and so it
really is a financial mechanism the New
Hampshire vaccine Association does not
set immunization policy it does not
receive any State funds and it doesn't
determine which immunization the state
purchases outstanding thank you thank
you represent torki I just want to
better understand the impact of this
bill that's coming to the floor on
Thursday in the financial impact
particularly for uh pediatricians or
Physicians up in the north country where
there's maybe one practitioner um maybe
not a large number of patients
and we know these vaccines can sometimes
be expensive but they also expire so
they need to have the dose at the right
time when the parent shows up with the
child that kind of thing could we
potentially find ourselves in a
situation where the doctors the
providers would not have vaccines ready
and available when a family shows up and
wants to give their child a vaccination
the short answer to that is yes we would
not um especially we saw this with RSV a
couple of years ago there was a new
vaccine for RSV for infants um and uh
the state could not purchase it
originally it could not be part of the
New Hampshire vaccine Association
because of the the um technical language
of the way our statue was written we
actually we've solved that we've
remedied that right now but early on in
that process this new the state of New
Hampshire could not participate so we
were able to get some um funds through
for Medicaid so that Medicaid kids could
have access to the RSV vaccine but there
was a physician in Norther in Coos
County that wasn't able to access it in
a timely way for his commercial paid
kids at that at that time and so it was
set up this process where some kids
could get access to vaccine and some
kids couldn't one of the things that our
vaccine program does once you sort of
Peel away some of the you know
ideological thoughts around vaccine is
we actually manage the control of them
as you can imagine these are really
sensitive pharmaceutical products
they've got to have you have to have
cold chain management and um both both
the the bulk purchasing allows us to
take that responsibility on and we can
manage that and be able to get the the
right number of vacines to the providers
as they need them so somewhat connected
to that with the most recent outbreak of
measles in Texas and the unfortunate
death um I believe it was last week
um this would the way I'm interpreting
it could potentially prevent people who
want a vaccine from getting a vaccine in
a timely manner uh could this open the
door to a possible outbreak of um any
one of these diseases here in New
Hampshire certainly I mean that's always
Our concern is that as we've seen
immunization rates drop over time and
families can choose what they want to do
for their own Children's Health but
there are a set of highly contagious
diseases for which we have school and
child care entry requirements for
vaccine those and it is for a very
limited number it's not covid we've had
this conversation many times the
department has never anticipated ated or
suggested that Co be a required vaccine
for school entry we're talking about
things like measles mumps and rubella
things that are highly contagious um and
have been managed for many years and as
we see um reduced vaccination rates
we're seeing this we're seeing measles
pop up more and more it's incredibly
virulent um we had our own measles
outbreak in the um Upper Valley last
summer small number five people but
still and it was a visitor to New
Hampshire who had meas and you know the
transmission happened in places like in
a store together you know and and so we
want to control that and we know that
measles is incredibly dangerous as well
to to kids health thank you
representative nvum yes thank you
chairman so if I my understanding is
correct the and you know it's this is uh
new to me the New Hampshire vaccine
Association they actually holding
inventories because you said they're
managing so their their their primary
role is negotiating a a bulk rate and U
so their primary role really is in
assessing the um anticipating with us
the number of vaccines that the
Department of Health and Human Services
is going to need we work with them we
share that information that we
anticipate to we are going to need
200,000 vaccines their role is to work
and negotiate with the commercial payers
the state does not have a role in that
they work with the commercial payers and
say how is they going to assess that
among their covered lives they use a
covered live methodology they gather the
money they give the money to us the
Department of Health and Human Services
purchases the vaccines so they're not
hold that Association really isn't
physically
holding um and but they are a financial
transaction and when you say they're
managing the the uh supply chain uh that
that's a quality assurance uh role
rather than physically handling the
supply chain is managed by the
Department of Health and Human Services
by public health
the role of the New Hampshire vaccine
Association is primarily
Financial okay so yeah and primarily
rate negotiation on on a bulk uh
basis thank you and the rate negotiation
depends upon a good estimate of
volume yeah all right representative
seaworth thank you Mr chairman my
questions actually for you should this
um bill that we're referencing pass I
saw it has a fiscal note do you expect
it if it makes it through Thursday
session to come before
us that's an excellent question I don't
know the
answer great so thank you um we'll move
on then to hospital acquired
affections
sorry I to response to your question it
should come before us the chair of
Finance has out the perview to wave it
coming to a second committee which would
prevent us from having the discussion on
the bill um I just wanted to clarify
that and then I believe representative
has a question yeah it's a thank you
it's a previous question on communicable
disease one it comes up every once in a
while it's in the in the news is what is
it Triple E the in uh yes does that is
that something that uh you're you're
dealing with that's an e uh sorry horse
has to do with in fact we're going to
talk a little bit about SL on slide 43
if you give me 30 seconds we'll get
there we'll talk about it um so super so
um additionally Small Program around
Hospital acquired infections for those
of you who are on HHS oversight we do a
report about Hospital inquired
affections every year we we um do both
training for hospitals as well as the
surveillance around watching whether
those infections go up or down and then
finally the large um uh account the last
large account in our bidic in our Bureau
of Infectious Disease Control is around
STD and HIV prevention again you'll see
some of the rebate money in there mostly
federally funded um and it provides
funding for no cost um and H STI and HIV
testing at the two City Health
departments as well as all the
investigation and monitoring of STI and
HIV in the state things like cyia which
is probably the thing that we have the
most reports on in that we don't
investigate every single case of
chlamydia but they are reported to us
and then other things like syphilis
gonorrhea um especially when we think
about syphilis among pregnant um
individuals that requires deeper
investigation and support along the way
um we have among the lowest rates in the
country of sexually transmitted
infections which is really uh something
that we want to maintain as we go
forward so so a question there um this
may be for Mr White it's unusual to see
this distribution of funds I I get the
10% I I I I don't understand how we got
to two % on General funds for um STD
prevention why are we doing 2% is that a
c a minimum effort thing or is that a
it's not a match it's likely cost
allocation but I will let Nathan correct
me if I'm
wrong I'm not I'm not questioning the
program I just want to understand why
we're doing 2% here
I I would have to look into it I suspect
there is a specific class line that may
not be eligible for federal or other
funds all right it's not it's not urgent
it just jumped out as a curiosity sure
um I'm I'm I'm 99% certain it's it's
because the positions are allocated but
we can verify that for you all right
representative priest thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um back on on uh page uh 40 on
accounting unit
5177 and
5178 M have there been any studies done
as to what would happen if these two
accounting these two programs or
accounting units went away how many
children would be
affected and I can tell so I we haven't
had a particular study there but I would
suggest that almost every child in New
Hampshire would be affected so this is
the way that we ensure that vaccines are
available again those common routine
childhood vaccinations measles mums
rebella verella common routine that
children are required to have for entry
into school and to child care there are
exceptions to that there's religious
exemptions to that there are exemptions
for health you know a child that cannot
take a particular vaccine because their
own medical need but every child would
be impacted by that um and what's the
fertility rate on that I each of those
each of those um conditions have their
own mortality R okay thank
you great super so I think that we um as
we go through the the next slides s
slides 42 and 43 just provide a little
bit more color again 42 talks a little
bit about the measles outbreak that I
was just referencing in um the upper
Valley Legionnaire's Disease again
something you might hear on the news you
might recall there was a particular case
last summer um L um linked to an
outbreak associated with a contaminated
cooling tower on the top of a hotel
again this is where the epies and the
data the disease investigators get their
you know um really do their hard work is
understanding we've got a bunch of
people who are all showing up with L
janela how what was the common exposure
and we were able to link it to a cooling
tower um in the North country and then
ultimately we had another very large
tuberculosis um exposure where an
individual exposed a large number of
children to their tuberculosis luckily
we were able to M mitigate any of the
impacts to
that um slide 43 has a little bit more
information if you need it around uh the
New Hampshire vaccine Association and
then slide 43 gets to the question
around arboviral disease um Triple E the
mosquito born illness we saw some incre
ined arboviral activity in 2024 we had
five human cases of Triple E which was a
large number and the first human case
since 2014 you may recall there were
some um AR the Triple E was around in
Southern New Hampshire um you know you
can play M that's one of those you can
blame Massachusetts for it because
Massachusetts also had an increase so
maybe with the mosquitoes were coming
over the Border um you I really I'm
going to point out because I really
appreciate if you get out your
magnifying glass there are very cute
little icons on here on the bottom
referring to cases in white tail deer
and horses that's what those little
animals are are pictured of and this is
a great example of where human health
and Animal Health really cross over um
at the end of the day so this was for
Triple E um we ensure human health but
of course we have to work closely um
around Animal Health to make sure that
humans are healthy so great we're doing
great for time moving on to the lab I
think representative Daniels has a
question yes before we leave the vaccine
uh I sense
that the whole episode with Co yes has
caused a lot of people to back away from
vaccines what is the division doing to
try to reinstall the confidence the V
the vaccines are are good man you know
that is a a wonderful question and
something that we have been thinking
about a lot and I think it's
fundamentally about trust um I think we
were bombarded with lots of information
during covid and people rightfully had
questions um and so I think what we can
do every time we show up here in the
legislature every time that we work
closely with Hospital providers and
medical providers we want to make sure
that families and individuals know that
they should be talking to their doctors
and their medical providers have really
good information about what's right for
them for vaccines that we can't um it's
it's not always instructive to Simply
say all vaccines are bad each of us have
different needs Childhood school
vaccines have been around a very long
time and they come from the age of where
we know what the impact of polio was we
knew what the impact of measles were and
those are diseases that are highly
contagious and have devastating
consequences within congregate settings
you have to remember kids come and spend
a lot of time at child care or in school
and they're like grimy we all you know
if you had a child they're grimy they
put their little hands they cough they
don't cover themselves it's a a place
that's primed for um some of those types
of infections to occur so I think coming
back and talking about why we've had
those vaccines for a long time and
ensuring that we are as transparent as
possible uh with um the efficacy and the
safety of those vaccines thank you so we
we had a discussion I think about a year
ago or so about um going on the DHHS
website and if you're a parent and
you're looking for advice on whether not
your child should have covid um uh that
website I think still clicks through to
the CDC without being apparent that
you've moved to the CDC and the CDC is
taking the position of pushing covid
where I think the New Hampshire position
as you've articulated before is if
you're curious about covid you should go
talk to your primary care
provider but we don't say that on the
website it it it clicks through to the
CDC uh Hawking their Co so I think what
we we have tried to fix many of those
links the the language we use on our
website as you know which is the talk to
your doctor for more information I can't
I didn't see that though I I I went in
there naively just thinking okay I'm a
new guy so I'll find I I'll find you
that link we did find one you you shared
with us one link it wasn't even Actually
I don't even think it was on the
immunization side but it went to an
agency that wasn't even CDC it was um
our uh the agency around preparedness
which had some stronger language around
covid vaccines we've taken that link off
the website okay and I wouldn't have
mentioned it except for the
representative Daniel's questions about
how do we build trust you know and one
of the ways we build trust is we admit
mistakes and there were some mistakes
that I think everyone from the CDC to to
New Hampshire could could uh make I
think I think what you will find from
this department is that we are very open
to having open conversations yeah all
right uh representative uh
no yeah thank you chairman and this is
just to build on that comment of how you
build trust one of the I think uh things
in my lifetime when I look at
vaccines uh that typically you think of
a vaccine with a possible exception of
in influenza vaccine but the vaccines
for
polio uh measles the the ones that
you're Comming saying pretty much
conform to the one one and done kind of
a message
so just so you know you're you're
talking about the CDC naming issue it
was the CDC that came out and helped
brand covid-19 injections as vaccines
and i' I've told those folks that that
was a mistake there's a big bigger
question because there's a change in in
uh the definition around vaccine you're
now dealing with the the covid was I
guess the Leading Edge of this but
you're going to see more of it and
that's where it's an MR you know Mna
it's um um um affecting yeah I'm just
saying I don't I don't think we can
resolve that here that's a federal issue
the question was how do you build trust
and that you know I think somebody's got
to tackle the question of traditional
definition of vaccines and and maybe a
new class of vaccines yeah I that that
point is well appreciated I will just
note that the reason like flu um and
covid changes every year and there's
like a recommendation for an annual
vaccine around that is because the
strain are different every year and so
you more effectively focus on the strain
that is prevalent and so that gets it
gets updated routinely and it's more
broadly distributed we haven't had a new
strain of measles thank goodness and one
final comment if you if you will is that
traditionally a lot of the vaccines were
egg based you know grown um from chicken
eggs or eggs you now have a whole new um
methodology of producing vaccines which
builds them up molecularly so there's a
whole issue around the definitional
structure and whole different
categories thank you did you want to
comment on that no all right I think
that's it so go ahead thank you so now
we are getting to our
laboratory that conducts Laboratory
Testing for disease prevention control
and did we hit the section that has your
epidemiology contract in it the
ELC did we covered that right that in
one of these slides there was I think so
so I I think we have a contract with UNH
for like $2.4 million p 40 cents and and
we and we basically buy time of uh an
epidemiology set of subject matter
experts is is it also may be connected
you know at one point that contract also
had other funds in it to do things are
like our state health Improvement plan
so that that could be part of the
confusion there we could take that
offline yeah great so ELC are um
provides that 100% Federal fund
um and it's allowing us to respond both
in the laboratory as well as disease
investigation to whatever is coming down
the pike we used ELC ELC was expanded
during covid it contracted at the end of
covid this is a real core funding um
that we get from
CDC um we can go down to 1878 not in
your budget book but we have a a small
amount of money of other funds that are
the water testing fees for laboratory
equipment specific for water testing um
this is a place where water testing used
to sit in the Department of
Environmental Services it was
transferred over to the division of
Public Health Services because uh
essentially Public Health Services owns
the lab and so it just made didn't make
a sense to have a a different agency
also having space in there and so we've
shared that and worked collaboratively
with Dees as as we do on so many
programs um this also tests so public
water sources private water sour ources
um shellfish and volunteer lake and
river stuff um we can skip down to the
public health laboratory fund again this
is our big chunk of change of General
funds to support laboratory functions um
for emergency resport uh response this
supports a lot of the actual
laboratorian laboratorians that's a word
I can never say but the folks who work
in the lab um are radiological support
and a lot of equipment this is the place
where if you were really digging into
the budget you'd see these huge
equipment numbers and it's really about
the fancy very expensive equipment that
we need to run those tests sir
representative Daniels has a question
thank you Mr chairman on testing of
private Wells is there any any situation
where the testing is
mandatory no not that I know of uh and
if someone were to test their well uh
and turn it into an independent lab do
those results get reported to the state
no and if if they use the state lab uh
did the results get maintained and are
there any bureaucratic nightmare that a
an individual must enter into that would
would cause them maybe not to want a
test there well no not not that I that
we have experienced in any way we're our
our fees are actually really inexpensive
um there's some there's a piece of
legislation right now to actually
increase our fees for that because in
some ways we are much less expensive
than those private testing companies and
we uh the costs have gone up so we would
like to get more in line to what the
commercials uh are are charging thank
you okay great um so we have some funds
in here um some more funds from the
Department of Environmental Services
this is a theme that you're hearing we
work really closely with Dees this is
for our P um imple and this does testing
for Pas testing in drinking water for
homeowners um and for private Wells um
and we've used some funds from um Dees
in order to to do that to implement that
work um we have our food emergency
response Network sometimes you'll see
that uh as an acronym of fern this is
where we c um conduct those food sample
testing and we're also there as well as
in a defense posture in case there were
ever contaminants purposely put into the
food system um through some sort of biot
terrorism and we look at both
microbiology chemistry radiochemistry so
you know all of those pieces both for
you know um organisms as well as
chemical things like lead or or arsenic
um we have a biom monetary biom
monitoring Grant this grant um is um
unfunded right now by the CDC but we are
it is unfunded but awarded so this
sometimes happens with a CDC Grant as
they get a smaller amount of money they
don't have enough money to give out to
everyone so they will unfund fund EST
state but they will have awarded it to
us so that if money does appear we would
be able to take it in and so by
budgeting it allows us to continue to do
the work of biom monitoring which we
have done for five years and those are
the major um uh accounting units of our
Laboratory um slide 47 you'll just see
some numbers I know you all love to look
at numbers over 16,000 water samples 25
200 samples from private Wells we've
tested Ed shellfish um we've tested
water samples for lead in the schools
our food testing again over 1500 samples
for bacteria alone a th over a thousand
samples for chemicals um and that uh
notice on the bottom is that arsenic um
where we found arsenic in the juice
boxes earlier on which of course no one
wants arsenic in juice boxes so um we
can move on unless there's any other
questions I'm just I'm just curious
about um external benchmarking are is
there anything that you're you know of
um where the states share with each
other the kind of workload they perform
and the kind of Manpower that they apply
to it to to develop some sort of a
workload
Benchmark so I know that we work closely
with our association which is the
association of Public Health
Laboratories to understand ntion have
some sort of larger vision of what other
um Public Health Laboratories experience
we go through some quality a lot of
quality improvement work we have our
Clea which makes sure that we are you
know we are outside regulated to make
sure that our testing is accurate so
some you know we pay for someone like
like ja in the hospital but we pay for
Clea to come and make sure that our
methods are correct and so we get some
sense of what um you know the number of
people to testing you know we have
General ideas I don't know that we have
a particular study that's done like a an
actual like this is how many people
should be on your bench to do X number
of why Services you know we certainly
lived that through covid as we e you
know grew by an extraordinary amount the
number of tests that we the covid tests
that we um tested over time and we were
able to flex up mostly using a a
temporary staffing contract and so we
were able to flex up and flex down in a
much easier way that we didn't add uh
positions to the state budget okay
um so just to close that idea out I
wonder if you've ever looked at what the
Army Medical department has for workload
metrics and you probably haven't be you
know because it's such an obscure
thought but um the Army Medical
department has workload standards on
almost everything you know and I I just
would be
curious um maybe as a side project and
some dull month to try to try to see how
we compare relative to what say the Army
Medical Department would allocate that's
a great idea there's never a dull moment
but um we can we can yeah there's not
going to be any outbreaks or anything
this year it's all going to be great uh
representative priest that's very
comforting to know um it's a point of
clarification back on uh 48 on the um
various Water Analysis yep laboratory
testings do you share this information
with a federal organization like CDC and
and they compare that to our neighboring
states to see if something bigger is
happening that we should be alerted of
yeah you know um I don't think we
specifically send this to CDC um because
much of this is funded by just um state
general funds but we certainly have
awareness and work with our regional
Partners all the time in looking at
those different um contaminants and this
is where we've started to understand
something like Pas so you know Pas is a
great example that there were some
health impacts and environmental impacts
at the same time and we were seeing them
simultaneously we you know we have't
elevated a more than expected number of
kidney cancer cases in marac um I can't
tie that to past but we know that there
is an increased amount of pasas in the
marac area you know we can't dot those
put a straight line between there but it
is interesting to look at those two
things and so we certainly work with our
national uh Partners at CDC at the um
Association for public health labor to
have a better understanding that New
Hampshire is not you know solely
focusing on um what's Happening Here
Without awareness of what's happening
outside the door okay thank you yeah um
Nathan pulled up that contract and if
you want to uh for the UNH
epidemiologist sure representative sewor
you want to have oh are you still
talking representative priest are you
done if you're if you're still got
questions okay representative seaworth
you had your yes
all right I'll jump in ahead of this but
mostly a question for you again I want
to jump back to that biom monitoring
Grant the one we said was awarded but
unfunded and I'm kind of thinking of
philosophically so if I look at the
expense items they all look like things
that if the money's there we can fund
them if it's not we don't correct
um when we are
confident or at least somewhat confident
that money might not show up what are
the advantages and disadvantages of
having it in the budget versus not
having it in the budget and having to go
to fiscal maybe if unexpected money
arrives sure so from a from a technical
perspective um this essentially provides
us the authority to spend those dollars
where were they to arrive if um if you
take it out of the budget
then what we would have to do is uh
prepare a fiscal item and we would send
that down typically the deadline for
fiscal is about a month in advance so
there would probably be a um a delay in
that and then after fiscal the item also
has to go through the executive counsel
process so they would have to
subsequently approve that so there may
be a a week or depending on the timing
of things or more delay on top of that
so it it would delay our ability to get
those funds by four to 6 weeks depending
on the specific schedule and then um
depending on the nature of what was
needed if if procurement was required or
or whatever it might be that may just
lead to some delays in initiating that
procurement until we have um pretty good
confidence level that it's going to be
approved thank you thank you to much
thank thank you Mr chairman
quick question on the uh
on slide 48 on the 203 water samples
tested for lead in schools is that
that's not 203 schools that's the the
samples at multiple samples at how how
many schools did that cover and do you
know I I wouldn't know the the number
right off the top of my head and I guess
the question is if you test a school is
that is that a you find not you know you
you I'm not sure what the process is you
have suspicion that there's lead Co
because it's an older school or this is
a partnership that we've had with the
Department of Environmental Services and
what I was speaking of when we just when
we started this afternoon which is um we
do some of the testing in partnership
with Dees Dees has funds to pay for the
fixing of the hardware but we are doing
the testing to see is there presence of
lead so first you test the water then
you find out what the source of it is
with um the hardware so I'm just
thinking that o over time um uh that
this should be a diminishing area of
lead Source because you got new schools
the old schools are either been tested
and remediated or eventually you would
hope that disappears in the schools 100%
this should this should be a very small
number moving forward okay thank
you I just wanted to acknowledge that my
neighborhood school um had a very large
number of water fountains and sinks that
tested high for lead um and I received a
lot of Outreach from very concerned
parents that were very thankful for the
program and that that testing was
happening and they were shut down and um
taken care of so I just want to say it's
a very good program and um like you said
hopefully we will deal with it and move
on and have safer product um in the
coming years thank
you uh relative to the question earlier
on the um the the contract with UNH for
the epidemiological support so the most
recent contract that was approved in May
of 2024 it was an extension for 3 years
and the um the extension included a
price limitation increase of
$635,000 total funds so that equates to
a little over $200,000 a year um and
about
46,000 of that each year is General
funds so on an annual basis it's a
little over $200,000 a year and and and
sometimes the confusion comes from the
fact that when we submit an item for GNC
approval we're we're modifying the total
price limitation and that total price
limitation can be over 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
years and the scope isn't necessarily
always consistent we do modify that over
that period of time so you do commonly
see individuals looking at that and not
realizing that the most recent action is
fairly isolated and different from the
total price limitation that you're
looking at and with the available amount
of funds we've flexed up and down the
number of of days and hours that we have
of for that epidemiologist so I just
want to be on the record of saying that
I can't tell you the exact number
without digging in there of how many
hours or or what FTE equivalency that
we're paying for so so if I'm looking
for a nugget to keep in my head it
sounds like it's about 64,000 in general
funds each year U um I apologize I may
misspoke about $46,000 of General funds
each year okay I may have transposed it
when I heard it
great thank you um so slide 49 again
just a highlight of some of the other
testing that we do Wastewater testing
for Respiratory viruses that we talked a
little bit about before really
interesting work that we're doing we
work with um I think 13 communities
around um testing their Wastewater and
then we also added in because it's you
know back to the fundamental nature of
the work that we do is rabies testing
this is something that you know doesn't
get out on TV very often um and we've
been doing for a very long time and we
have the responsibility of working
closely with fish and game um and as
well as the department of safety to
address rabies um this is actually
probably one of the most sensitive
things that we test the risk uh it has
incredible risks to human health because
once symptoms develop from raises from a
person there's nothing you can do about
it it will lead to death rabies is bad
news that's all I have to say about that
um we can go
into very quick question if if you will
may I yes may I very quick question on
the testing for for influenza so you're
testing for the you know the influenza
is constantly evolving in fact the
Pharma companies are making an educated
guess on what by the time they do the
vaccines what they think the strain is
going to be so this test this tests for
identifiable strains or I yeah it's part
it's part of a a multi-prong effort
around influ fluza um that we have we
can test for it in the Wastewater often
the idea around Wastewater testing is
it's a little bit of a canary in the
coal mine you can sometimes see disease
before it actually presents clinically
it'll show up in the Wastewater so it
gives you an idea where you might have a
hot spot in a in an in the state um or a
region of the state for respiratory
disease we also do other testing for
influenza again for confirmatory testing
for hospitals Sentinel um sources so
that we have an understanding of where
influenza is spreading in the community
thank you great and and we know that
influenza is Incredible cost driver and
real cost to human health especially
among older adults um and um the you
know we have seen and we've been working
with the hospital Association this year
they have not shuttered the doors but
they've they have been very full this
year with all respiratory diseases from
covid to RSV to influence it has been a
bad year in New
Hampshire all right um slide 50 we begin
to dig into our emergency preparedness
response and recovery program um again
you'll recall that this was a a program
that used to be housed within our office
of commissioner um back during pre
pandemic and in the beginning days of
the pandemic during the pandemic we
moved it within the division of Public
Health Services simply because of the
degree to which that we were working
hand inand every single day um it was
also a bit of a span of control it made
more sense given the funding sources for
that to sit with within the division of
Public Health Services and so this um
our uh Bureau of emergency preparedness
and response really crosses lots of
areas it works closely with the
Department of Safety Homeland Security
it mans some of the ESF functions the
emergency service functions around
medical and housing for the entire State
um in addition to helping us within
Public Health in particular to the sort
of incidents that we have around
tuberculosis measles or other infectious
disease events those tend to be the
largest number of things but this group
also um uses some of its fund or
resources and you know based on its
General funds can do things like um when
the eclipse was happening up north they
were sent up north to help with that to
make sure that we had adequate first aid
for all of the tens of thousands people
who came to visit up North so if we go
into um slide 50 um or 51 uh this is
where my slides are out of order so I
apologize um we have some federal funds
here for um a little bit of funds uh and
more General funds to help prepare and
respond to radiological incidents um we
then dive into Hospital preparedness we
work very closely with the hospitals um
there's actually match that the
hospitals requ that is required to the
federal funds that comes from the
hospitals and the amount of money that
they invest in this work and this is
really helping them be able to be
prepared to handle any um emergency
within the the hospital or Health Care
setting we have um another large funding
area this the most significant amount of
funds is in something we call fet public
health emergency preparedness I have a
question there yes on the emergency
preparedness I it looks like it's 9%
General funds it's uh the the you you
all requested a increase from 536 to 736
in general funds and the governor
knocked it back to your your 536 and
might I'm looking at the uh the budget
briefing book page
50 okay and I I think that's associated
with uh the pH emergency
preparedness
114 is this is this a is this a required
match the 9% what how did how did we
come up with that number 9 sure so
there's a there's a 10% match and
there's spend one unfunded position in
this area which I believe accounts for
the difference between the agency and
the governor's budget um and and that
that that's that's where that reduction
is coming from
um Bia Bia uh or bayum to bayum um we
also move to positions elsewhere within
Public Health as well
yeah okay so um so this is this may be
the one narrow example of how we open
today's session
uh about how um pre
pandemic uh we had a different sizing
and spending level than we do now and we
went from in 24 to 349 up to
536 and I'm I'm just curious about the
incremental justification for that that
level of growth so so the the state
fiscal year 24 you were referring to the
actual general fund spending that year
right I'm looking at at just slide 50
I'm not looking at the the hb1 I'm
looking just at what your briefing book
says so it's the actual in 24 was 349
according to this document and it jumped
in 25 to 536 and that's where the
governor is maintaining it in 26 and 27
but I'm just curious about the change
from 24 to 25 sure so it it may be a
little bit more complicated of a story
because the use I'm just looking at this
so if I look at what was budgeted in
this accounting unit in accounting unit
let me see here 114 so there was
554 million or
$554,000 budgeted within this accounting
unit in state fiscal year 24 and so the
actual spend was lower than that I
suspect there's a couple of
contributors um contracts line was not
fully spent there were vacancies that
led to that and so I I don't know if
there were a couple of key positions and
retirements that occurred that year um
it that would have
been oh we've got a we yep we've got
someone who can speak to it if we
may well welcome just state your name
for the record and and get the mic
really close closer can you hear me now
yeah okay I'm shelle Swanson the finance
director for public health um in fep our
general funds are only in our contracts
line and that is our match for the grant
um so what you're seeing the difference
is because we didn't spend all of our
contract money um so it's 10 most of the
contracts are 10% General funds so the
the small amount spent is because the
contracts weren't all the contract
appropriation wasn't all spent all right
doesn't have anything to do with
position so that's encouraging some
other questions can I but can I go you
questioned the changes from our agency
to the governor and that was because in
our agency we erroneously budgeted
General funds in our positions which we
don't normally do so we caught that when
um we were going through our agency and
we asked the governor's office to
rectify that so that's what they did for
us good catch that yeah so so when you
say you underspent contract money in
24 what was the
impact what what something bad must have
happened I don't think anything bad
happened um where uh fep is one of our
grants where we allowed to um we uh
given expanded Authority so if we're not
able to get our work done in one year
we're um allowed to bring the grant
funds forward um and when the contracts
are encumbered all that money rules
forward so we can do that work in the
next year and and I would just add to
that this is a place also that it
because we have that Dynamic ability to
flex between years there are times that
we CH change our Direction so it may be
that we were not doing something we
switched what we were doing and we
created a new um uh path forward so you
know it's it's pretty Dynamic we can get
you the detail of the difference in
those contracts but it doesn't
necessarily reflect coming from in my
questions is I'm a former plans officer
and I realize that there are times where
you have to have a plan and you never
execute the plan but you go back and you
revisit a plan and you update a plan and
it doesn't add a tremendous amount of
value and so so I I'm just you know as
tight as things are I'm just looking if
there's even a few hundred, thousand
here yeah I I I appreciate that comment
planning is you know you plan for the
knowns and then the unknown unknowns as
well so that's that is the whole purpose
of this group and then to be able to be
ready to react in a moment's notice and
so the plans are helpful um all the time
so that you're ready to
go represent the no vacum yes I uh I
don't know if it's exactly Hospital
preparedness but one of the places that
generate a lot of biohazard uh waste are
hospitals yes and so my question is
who has the responsibility and what does
the whole process look like for uh
controlling where those wind up and what
uh how how the chain of command and
everything else because there's some
really there's some stuff that probably
is not all that hazardous but there's a
whole bunch of stuff that is yes so
public health does not have the
authority to do that we don't do that
work in particular of managing their
waste product I would imagine that Dees
handles some of that um and we can
probably find out exactly where that is
but that is not in this particular role
where we would come into play is again
when there might be a terrorism
bioterrorism threat or some other
chemical we or chemical threat we can
test for that in our laboratory and then
we have some response to the action so
these folks are really the responders
and help us manage the incident if and
when it ever happens we are thankful
when we do not have an incident yeah I'd
be interested in that information
because you know anybody that's been to
a hospital every replace you see
biohazard yes uh waste material and um
um just wondering how that all is uh is
managed thank
you all right um another note on this
slide on slide 51 the Public Health
crisis response um just for you to know
this is um budgeted but it is not it is
also not funded right now this is a
placeholder that uh has been developed
um historically within our budget so
that when there is an emergency we have
a mechanism to accept those money
quickly and expend them quickly to the
point of um what Nathan described with
the other unfunded but awarded this way
we can move quickly it's even more
important here um where we might
anticipate funds for something like bird
flu if bird flu were to if we were to
find bird flu in this community and
there was a risk to human health we
would get federal funds we would put
them in this um line item and we would
be able to expend them immediately both
on things like overtime as well as any
contracts that we would need to do so it
is there's no actual money in here it's
simply just
budgeted um you can go on to slide 52 we
have our radiological emergency response
we get some funds from the Department of
Safety that they get from that is
assessed from Seabrook and um this is
allowing us to respond to a radiological
event the public Health's response is
really about the health impacts of that
radiological event if it were to occur
um and those are the large those are all
of the funding streams in our emergency
um preparedness slide 53 you'll just
sort of see the the scope of the work
again around what we do the fact that we
on slide 54 we're you know constantly
training people and staff and volunteers
that's part of our work you know to your
question around what would what would
happen if the plan didn't happen well
one of the things that we're responsible
for is training volunteers so that
they're ready to go to administer
vaccine if it's some sort of vaccine um
related event or an event that would
need an immediate vaccine we are
constantly working with commun
Volunteers in the community to be able
to respond quickly if there's an
emergency one of those emergencies
you'll see on slide 55 um just happened
and luckily there was no loss of life
but you may recall seeing in the news
that there was a fire at an assisted
living facility in conquered and our
team got the call um 9:00 at night 8:00
at night to help with the fact that
there was the assisted living facility
had um to move its residents and so our
team worked with the First Responders
with Homeland Security to ensure that
families were connected to their loved
ones who were in that assisted living
facility we found that a number of the
fam their families were local were able
to come meet up with their family member
take them home take them to safety um
the individuals were moved from Granite
Ledges into the conquered Hospital
cafeteria and our team was there ready
to act ready to support immediately and
were there until the we hours of the
morning luckily no loss of life everyone
was healthy but part of the reason for
that is that we had a well-oiled machine
of what would do what we would do in a
mass casualty
event and that's it for emergency
preparedness thank you
we are at the very last Bureau just
forecasting so I appreciate your stamina
through here um we are at our Bureau of
prevention and wellness beaw um this is
this is the place where we have some of
our um more chronic diseases and cancer
work um it is
um interesting to think if we think
about the national what's going on at a
national level right now we know that
the new secretary for Health and Human
Services secretary Kennedy is very
interested in chronic diseases we will
be interested to see what direction um
that the feds will go in in this place
but he certainly came into his role
saying that chronic disease was going to
be a prim uh a priority for him so we're
we're anxious to see what that will mean
for us um we also know in public health
that things like infectious disease and
chronic disease also are inter uh really
play with each other are integrated we
know things like even if you have oral
health concerns that that can impact
your heart or impact premature labor if
you're a pregnant woman and you have an
infectious disease all of it is so
interdependent at the end of the day so
our BPA looks at Primary Care Services
making sure that we have access to our
federally qualified Health Centers we
have the the um data around that we have
um make sure to support our rural Health
Centers and our small hospitals or
critical access hospitals this works on
chronic disease risk factors um
addressing the unique needs in our rural
community improving access to screening
early detention and management that
includes our breast and cervical cancer
screening program that has been around
for a very long time that's very
important and ultimately we have um some
the uh grant called the opioid data to
action so looking at opioid data um
overdose and um as well as our
prescription drug monitoring program is
also nestled within this
Bureau we have a just a few more pages
left of of budget so three more pages of
budget and then then you can call it a
day um the first couple of oral Health
Grants are pretty small we have some
work in tobacco prevention and cessation
um and so this fun has both Federal and
general funds within it and this
provides funds for our Quit Line um it
carries out some educational campaigns
especially around quitting for older
adults we find that most people are in
their you know uh Middle Ages and older
when they get if they've had a lifetime
of smoking usually it's the health
conditions that really then make them
consider it's time to quit and we
provide some resources around Quit Line
we also do a lot of primary prevention
work with youth and adolescents to
prevent them from smoking including
vaping along at at the end of the day um
so we had about um yes I'm just getting
ahead of myself here uh in our
Comprehensive Cancer program this is uh
another place where we have a small
amount of General funds that are a
required match um and our comp cancer um
includes our breast and cervical cancer
program that screen helps with screening
and diagnostic costs for mammograms and
cervical cancer screening for um
individuals who are lowincome between
the ages of 22 21 and
64 um I'd like to come back to the
tobacco prevention great okay that's a
3565 breakdown between General funds and
federal funds is that a required match
is that a no additional funds were added
to this over the past several bium to
specifically support Outreach to
adolescence around vaping and other
preventative
activities okay so the the 3565
breakdown is just coincidental yes okay
um now this program may have contributed
to some success where at historic lows
of of cigarette smoking I
believe um and and the um General funds
projection on this is set to be
607k for quite a
while um what what was your thinking
here and and maybe maybe you need to
bring somebody up but what was your
thinking here on uh why this could
remain stable during projected
inflation um you know what kind of
metrics you're using so that we know
that this is money well spent I mean it
it sounds good but is it effective great
thank you I think that's those are
always important questions to ask so P
you know this is the problem with
prevention is you never can stop you
know you can we've got youth coming on
there are new products all the time that
are coming on the on the scene we saw
that certainly like pre 2018 2019 we had
seen um traditional cigarette use among
youth go down which we're all very
excited about we''ve you know made some
societal shifts around the acceptability
of smoking as well as environmental
shifts around where you can smoke and
where you can't smoke um many of us
probably remember having smoking areas
in school um and that's certainly we're
a long time away from having a smoking
area outside the cafeteria or even maybe
in the cafeteria if you're a little bit
older than I am so that's that's
important and that's real savings to
Medicaid and to healthcare moving
forward we then saw in the 2017 2018 all
of a sudden this influx of Vape on the
market um and we all of a sudden saw
those rates rise way up and that became
socially acceptable among kids and so
since then and if you look at the data
on I think it is on slide 62 you know we
saw it Spike up in 2019 the the amount
of Youth um use of Vape products and
then it starts to come down in 21 and
then sort of levels to 23 and so that
suggests to me that we still have some
work to do as we look at uh and this
data comes from that youth RIS
behavioral survey this is the only way
that we really can have a good sense of
how many kids are using these products
so we're looking at this data to say um
in multifactoral ways like where in the
community as you look at the map here
are there places where this is more
prevalent where should we put be putting
in those prevention activities so we're
maintaining that level so that we can be
dynamic and continue to make that push
to try and reduce those those numbers
one of the things we know about vaping
as well is that it it has um often
translated into using combustible
cigarettes or regular traditional C
cigarettes which we know are even more
harmful the jury is still out on the
complete harm around vaping it's not
good I don't think anybody will tell you
it's good for you um we're going to have
to understand over decades to know what
the long-term effects
are and then another on this this
67,000 how how much of that uh ends up
going into contracts to uh vendors that
do things for us probably a good bit of
it goes into and and I could ask someone
to look at the actual budget in front of
me but many we we use vendors so we have
a vendor um called uh National Jewish
Healthcare it's based out of uh Colorado
that helps run our Quit Line we don't
have the capacity to run a quit line
here in New Hampshire and they do a Quit
Line both that's traditional for adults
sort of aimed again at that older adult
market and they also do text based work
for teens because we know that text no
teen is going to call I mean again if
any of you know a teen they don't
actually talk on phones um but we have a
text based um support program for that I
don't know were you going to say
something uh so 100% of the of the
general or the contracts 100% of of that
is is generally fund or the general
funds are in there at 100% I think from
a historical perspective if you look at
the current Bia when we prepared our um
our agency budget request we prepared at
the same level the general funds were
essentially kept at the same level as
they are currently for the 26 27 budget
okay could so could I get like the top
three most expensive four most expensive
contracts in this area not not the
contracts but a very short summary of of
what we're spending uh I don't need to
know who we're spending it with I don't
need the vendor name but I want to know
the purpose we are likely spending it
for the Quit Line and then to do some of
the prevention activities for youth um
we can get that for you but off the top
of my head that's where we're spending
majority of those funds okay because I I
really I really do want to take a deep
dive on this line we can get that for
you representative Mooney did you have a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
I am uh very curious about this line in
one regard I certainly understand the
health effects of smoking and this is
very important uh but looking forward
the New Hampshire house has passed now
on countless occasions the legalization
of marijuana I know we have a governor
that makes it very clear she will veto
that effort however if that were to pass
what would happen to this line would it
uh become larger than it is now would it
increase or would it become
irrelevant or somewhere in between thank
you I thank you very much that's a a
really insightful question so I don't
think it would become irrelevant I don't
anticipate that there would be
additional funds um in this particular
line I know that in many of the packages
that we've seen for legalization of of
recreational use of cannabis there have
been a a p sort of a fund a public
health fund that's pulled out of it and
a prevention fund and so there are ideas
that you would have funds for both um
prevention for cannabis use among youth
that might occur within Public Health
that might occur within the division of
Behavioral Health servic I don't you
know without the funds being
appropriated we didn't get to that
granular level of sort of who was going
to run what we work very closely tobacco
and um substance misuse in fact when I
was here when um director Fox was
talking we talked a little bit about why
tobacco wasn't in that budget so tobacco
is typ typically in public health the
substances is in Behavioral Health so I
would anticipate that if if the um if
there were to be recreational Cannabis
there has been a lot of support and a
lot of advocacy for ensuring that there
is the prevention components and also
sort of managing some of the
environmental parts of it we get into
that now of like secondhand smoke um you
know how do you incorporate things like
the secondhand smoke from Canabis as
well and and in housing in restaurants
all of that the the slightly different
thing with cannabis is that the actual
use of it um from what we understand or
at least I could talk about the
therapeutic program the um there's less
use of just combustible cannabis or like
flour or smoking a joint if I can speak
plainly um and there's a growing use of
using Edibles and things that don't
produce that same sort of
smoke thank you representative n vano
yeah thank you thank you Mr chairman I
want to come back to a comment that uh
you made in connection with oral oral
health yeah and uh I think it's pretty
widespread acknowledgement that
inflammation as a general thing is is uh
underlies almost uh a lot of areas of uh
disease and my question has to do with
the fact and a lot of inflammation
starts uh with dental dental hygiene so
I'm just wondering what uh what efforts
are me to to link some of this because
anybody that go you know I talked to my
dentist uh about paradon uh stuff that
there's not doesn't seem to a lot of
literature a lot of study related to the
linkage between uh dental health and the
preventative aspects of good dental
health uh uh in preventing other
diseases I think this is an area we have
a ton more education need that needs to
be done to do those links because I
think there is certainly some suggestion
in the literature right now to your
point around heart disease around other
conditions that are linked to that
inflammation so in the oral health
programs that are funded by the division
of Public Health those are school-based
clinics often where um we're going out
and doing um sealant um for fluoride
fluoride sealant and Fluoride Varnish
and sealant those are two different
things but both effectively help to
prevent cavities or carries among
children and then historically this is a
place where we've been Dynamic we had a
number of community-based Dent oral
health programs that would do that for
adults we've pulled back on that to some
degree now that we have a Medicaid
benefit so again Public Health was in
there when there wasn't a Medicaid
benefit um and even as we've seen kids
access their care you know some of those
school-based clinics are a little bit
you know have less participation because
we have better access but until we have
great access both for adults and kids
these clinics are really helpful for
acting as a safety net especially in
communities that have some real
vulnerable folks or or low-income folks
yeah it just seems to me that there's
huge potential for from the preventative
side of addressing the Dental which in
turn would reduce the incidence of
inflammation cause you know that causes
uh other diseases yeah it's exactly why
we put our oral health program and our
chronic disease program okay thank you
thank you um I am on slide 58 um so we
have a number of um two on here that are
larger funding funded programs we have
something called Wise Women which is
about 1.4 million in CDC funds no
General funds and this provides a lot of
support primarily through our federally
qualified Health Centers to per to work
with women in particular around heart
disease and stroke and really promoting
lifestyle factors so we all know about
the medications you can take we also
know that diet and exercise are really
important and so this wise wom program
really supports our fqhcs and other
places where low-income women are to be
able to do some of those lifestyle
factors support them in exercise
programs support them in in healthy diet
so that we can help um mitigate the
impact of a cardiovascular disease um
similarly we have down and combined
chronic disease these are 100% federal
funds as well um and this is also where
we're doing a lot of quality improvement
in our federally qualified Health
Centers even our community mental health
centers to make sure that we can connect
the dots um that our health centers have
the resources so they can identify
people both at risk and who suffer from
chronic diseases and make sure that we
Implement some of those lifestyle
improvements um that really are going to
be beneficial in the long run and really
it's about self these programs are
primarily around self-management being
able to manage your own disease as well
as ensuring that we have the right me
you know at times we do some quality
improvement around medication for
hypertension things like that we can go
to um slide
59 um these again we have two smaller
grants that work with the rural
hospitals and Rural health centers um we
have our rural health and primary care
which is again um on uh budget briefing
book 62 this is where you see our state
loan repayment program something that we
often talk about where we provide loan
repayment to medical professionals both
Physicians MDS dentists all the way down
to Master's level providers primarily in
the behavioral health space incredibly
important to do both the workforce uh
recruitment as well as the state loan
repayment so that we can focus those
folks in serving our most needed
residents of the state they have to sign
a contract and say they'll work in this
um area where they can where there's
more need and then finally on that that
page we have something called our
preventive Health block grant um which
also has a required match to it which is
the general funds on there um and this
is a flexible set of funding from CDC
and this funds a ton of things from our
rabies clinic all the way to um a lot of
work in our laboratory but it's
generally for disease prevention and
health promotion some nurses
occasionally get funded out of here but
this is a broad um flexible funding
source that we can use for ongoing needs
and also as needs change over
time I I have a question on uh rural
health and Primary Care yes um so uh in
the current year we're we're at a A
million6 or 7 we're going up um 100,000
into
26 uh what what what's constituting that
100,000 increase what's that based
on I'm just looking at the general funds
okay I'm obsessed with General funds
okay Nathan's going to pull that up for
you okay and so so I'll ask you maybe a
different question then which is um do
we do we have a little
synopsis on exactly uh how these
scholarships the scholarship amounts are
determined and and and what kind of
income eligibility uh the the applicant
may need to meet or I I I I just want to
understand if we're if we're paying
$5,000 for a podiatrist and 50,000 for a
you know a nurse anesthetist I I I want
to know if there's a distinction based
on uh
credentialing yes there is let me pull
up I have some cheat sheet here so I I'm
I might need it to like look at it and
absorb it okay so I we're happy to send
that to you so again um when we think
about the um State loan repayment we H
we base the loan they enter into a
contract with us and it is uh the
different levels so like an MD receives
more for loan re loan re ment than a
master's level clinician so it's divided
by that level of MD level versus
Master's level versus RN level so
there's a set formula that we use for
loan repayment they get that formula and
they have to be serving in an medically
underserved area so often that's in our
federally qualified Health Center or a
Community Mental Health Center primarily
so so so just to let you know my my
general concern as I as I go into this
with you later um
these General funds get paid by you know
plumbers and carpenters and people who
drive trucks you know there's a lot of
those uh skills up in the north country
that are also underserved and we're not
um subsid not subsidizing is not the
right word we're not
incentivizing those skill sets to go
into that area and so there's I think
there's a fundamental fairness question
to this program and I I just I just want
to take a fresh fair look at it I think
that's fair you know I would suggest
that those plumbers and you know other
folks all need healthc care and
especially if in your in Coos you need
to be able to access a doctor yeah a
nurse needs a plumber too though so it's
it's a mutual need Society it's a maslo
hierarchy of needs I think we also need
healthc care providers to have optimal
lives so that you can be a plumber so
that you don't have the chronic disease
that keeps you out of work so you know
it's a healthy conversation to have
public health problem if you don't have
plumbers well that's the part about the
septic system that the health officers
take care of but um but truly you know
all kidding aside I think over time we
have prioritized ensuring that we have
access to qualified health providers in
every corner of the state because
naturally it is harder to get a a great
doctor to work up north or out in the
community than it is in the Boston metro
area so so so I've spent 50 years in
healthc care I love the industry I love
our professionals I understand the rural
environment uh I I I I I'm still just
troubled by the fundamental fairness of
of of the program when we're not doing
it for similarly shortage skills yes so
if if we could just look at it thank you
all right great um are there any other
questions here we have some data around
slurp later in a slide if you just want
to see how the uptake on it in a bit all
right um slide 50 uh slide 60 just the
last few of these this is our
prescription drug monitoring program no
General funds in the prescription drug
monitoring that was designed when the
program was designed just a you know a
memory for memory lane um prescription
drug monitoring used to be an oplc in
the office of professional Li Insurance
certification it moved over to um the
Department of Health and Human Services
in public health this is one of those
places where our net number got a little
bit bigger but took a program that was
existing in another part of the state
and put it in public health um we have
some funds through the Department of
Justice and then some federal funds to
do that work we also have some opioid
surveillance funding um that really
looks at overdose data in a in a pretty
comprehensive way um and so that's it
for all of our budgets for the division
of Public Health Services again as you
go through the the remainder slides
these are just some highlights of the
great work that the team behind me does
around you know the 1500 people that are
served through um bccp for breast and
cervical cancer screening the number you
know 689 adults in our arthritis program
doing some healthy active living work um
and some great work that we're doing in
diabetes prevention great data here in
six side 62 around um vaping around
youth vaping and the way that that plays
what I it was a little too busy but I
think it is interesting to note we have
flip-flopped over time around boys and
girls talking about how do we use this
yrbs data there's um girls are more
likely to start vaping earlier which is
fascinating to me early on it was all
mostly boys and then finally the last
slide of any consequence slide 63 talks
about the state loan repayment program
and um shows that increase specifically
among Behavioral Health Providers so
that is um 2:15 which is almost exactly
when we thought we would be done um and
I'm happy to answer any more questions
and I I appreciate your patience with me
as um as I came in to pinch hit today I
you're again you're great so let's look
at at slide 61 supporting healthy active
lives I think we have a question about
um the extent to which we ought to be
monitoring Alzheimer and dementia if
there's anything we should be doing
that's sort of in a similar vein here so
typically the work around Alzheimer's
and other dementias has been within our
um divisional long-term services in in
healthy aging that's where you know
we've divided the pi so um Public Health
has not taken a a lead role in that
space but our aging work our folks who
do adult and elderly services which is
not their name anymore but I'm blanking
on their new name um that's where the
work of Alzheimer's happens all right um
representative n van yeah um I'm not
sure whether it was covered uh in a
previous session that I had but it
uh or whether it's U appropriate to ask
it here on the whole question of um
licensing of
nurses and uh reciprocity and what uh is
that in in your that's in a different is
that would occur within the office of
professional lure and
certification yeah because I I think
I've I think I asked the question but
I'm not sure I got the answer and that
is one of the things that uh occurs to
me my my wife is a retired nurse but
there's often uh difficulties in
accepting accreditation and everything
else that could alleviate some of
the yeah absolutely and I think that
that's a place with the Board of Nursing
and and oplc that they're wrestling with
that but we certainly agree and we see
that in the healthcare providers that um
around the state that some of those
licensing and credentialing issues um
are best address well they are uh
statutorily need to be addressed within
oplc instead of DHHS so so the Loan
program for example uh is that a so if
you attract a nurse from another uh
location uh who had the loans
outstanding they be able to access that
kind of a program or this is they would
have to be licensed here in New
Hampshire and ready to work in New
Hampshire right I mean they could sign
the same kind of an agreement it said
I'm I'm uh newly graduated or I
graduated a while ago and I still have
outstanding loans they would be able to
qualify assuming they met the
contractual Arrangements correct and
they were serving in those medically
underserved areas correct okay thank you
thank you representative prce thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question and for your being here today
and being so responsive and
knowledgeable and all your staff behind
you and the great work that they're
doing um do you have any uh numbers on
page uh
59 on accounting unit
um
2794 and
3165 how are these programs working out
are you getting any professional medical
help in these areas that we are needing
in um so you're looking at slide 20 2794
yeah 2794 so yes so we've been working
closely with bate Primary Care they have
been our contractor to do Recruitment
and so so yes over time and we can share
those numbers with you as well of the
numbers of providers that we have been
able to attract within the state and
make sure that they are located
primarily for us in those medically
underserved areas again public health is
making sure that everybody has a access
to healthare so we can we can get you
that information that would be great
thank you thank
you I think that's uh it any further
member question questions um you have
any summary final thoughts for us on
this section Mr or commissioner no other
than to thank you all for your attention
and your thoughtful questions um I think
you've given our team some things to
think about you've certainly given us a
little bit of homework to get back to
you on we really appreciate your
attention you know I'll come back to the
less than 2% of the general funds in the
Department of Health and Human Services
are in public health um so you know that
doesn't make your job any easier at the
end of the day but given that I've been
very impressed with the degree to which
we've worked over four hours now to talk
through um the breath of the work so
thank
you all right uh Mr White thanks for
having us here today okay do we have uh
comments from the
public I I'm not seeing it oh you yes
come on up new Futures
right thank you for your time
you state your name for the for the
clerk and the record absolutely my name
is Kate fry I'm the vice president
advocacy did you get that represent NCO
did you get
the fry I can give you a
card okay excellent thank you thank you
very much for offering public comment
I'll be very brief because I know it's
been a long day um I'm very uh thankful
to the divisional Public Health Service
is for their presentation um we support
a lot of different areas within the
division of Public Health budget um
obviously we care about uh health and
wellness policies and are very concerned
about prevention programs starting at
Birth all the way uh through the Life
Span so we do support um The Family
Resource Centers the comprehensive
family child supports also childhood
lead poisoning prevention um and I also
just did want to mention that we are
very supportive of our Universal
childhood vacc program and we do have
serious concerns about House Bill 524
the last thing I'll just say is just an
anecdotal story about um vaping um I've
worked in public health for about 20
years and both my college age girls
ended up vaping um and uh they both
through their providers re were referred
to the Quit Line and they were
successfully able to text back and forth
and I'm happy to say both are no longer
Bing good
so I have a straight question for new
Futures looking at the public health
budget is there any area here that you
think we've over resourced that we maybe
be able to take some money from to
support more higher priorities it's a
very difficult question and I take it on
um a lot harder because I used to work
in the division of Public Health
Services so I don't envy any of you
about making these difficult decisions
um I think as I said we're very
concerned for we are very attentive to
prevention programs um however I think
there are a lot of very important
programs within this budget so
unfortunately I can't guide you to one
specific line and I don't envy your
position yeah I I I want to also just
mention that um a member of new Futures
contacted me before the session started
this year like in the fall and was
asking for support on expanding the
adult Medicaid dental Medicaid program
MH and I explained that this was not the
year to to be doing that and I I I
appreciate that new Futures didn't take
try to take that Hill anyways no we did
we did not that's what not one of our
budget priorities that would have been
in the division of Medicaid services and
I don't believe we prioritize that all
right is there anyone else in the
audience come on
up thank you for your
testimony thank you Mr chairman Mike
Rolo American Cancer Society cancer
Action Network I'm going to be very
brief and and and somewhat repetitive
what Kate fry just said um the Cancer
Society has a number of budget
priorities as well as you can imagine
the cancer registry might be one of them
um the uh tobacco control program is one
of them in the comprehensive uh cancer
um uh line is another um area as well as
the office of rural Health we' be uh
supportive of of the funding levels that
are within uh that were presented today
all right so similar question do you see
any areas that we could reduce funding
to support your
priorities uh no I believe that the
department and the governor presented a
a budget that um um is reasonable and uh
no I I don't believe that uh within the
Department of Public Health that there's
probably room to make Cuts if it's only
2% of the overall call them
recalibrations here but thank you of
course um all right um anything else oh
I yes I did want to remind you all that
it's you've probably seen it in your
calendar and that there will be an
announcement on the floor on Thursday
but we have our annual legislative
luncheon on Thursday in the cafeteria
from noon to 1:30 and we'd love to have
you all there and we have volunteers
that will actually be talking a little
bit about some of your budget priorities
so great uh representative priest do you
have a question yes I do thank you I'm
more of a comment I want to just thank
you and your Association for everything
you do being a cancer survivor and
hearing you know and hearing and seeing
people around me becoming diagnosed with
cancer I mean this is a disease that's
not going away and so we can I I I
appreciate your being there and your
priorities thank you thank you
representative appreciate it all right
thank you Mr CH yes sir thank you thank
you for taking a what is was
intentionally a tough
question it it it's the one that we're
struggling to find the answer
to um come on up and introduce
yourself thank you for letting me go um
last so that I can answer your question
maybe um my name is Christine Stoddard I
represent by state Primary Care
Association and I'm happy to give you my
card um for your notes so we represent
New Hampshire's community health centers
and Vermont's community health centers
in New Hampshire our health centers
serve over a 100,000 Granite Staters and
they exist in areas that are designated
as medically underserved or have
residents who um are designated as
medically underserved
populations so we exist um to help
people Access Health Care Services that
they would otherwise go without our
health centers do receive limited
Federal funding that hasn't been changed
in a decade and we also rely on state
contracts and Commercial Insurance to um
do this work our health centers serve
approximately 36% commercially insured
and about the same in Medicaid it
depends on the health center um and we
do have some uninsured patients but I I
just wanted to speak to offer us as a
resource to you we do as um Trish
mentioned manag the recruitment center
contract with the state of New Hampshire
and so we work with people across the
country who want to come to New
Hampshire and practice in our beautiful
state and we've been doing that work for
over 30 years in partnership with the
state and we've recruited well over 700
clinicians so we're happy to give you
any data that would be helpful for you
as you craft the budget um but to
anticipate your question I don't think
you could ever overspend on prevention
right I I mean as a personal it's a
personal choice too um how do you spend
your money in your personal budget I try
and prevent big expenses so I think the
state can do the same and the division
of health is very responsible with their
Investments and we've had a wonderful
relationship partnering with them on
everything from covid to healthcare
Workforce recruitment so happy to serve
as a resource to you as you make these
tough decisions thank you may I ask a
question you didn't anticipate
absolutely uh since you uh have had so
much experience recruiting uh
professionals from out of state what do
you think would be more effective if you
could only do one of two things would it
be more effective recruiting out ofate
professionals if you offered some basic
relocation package or a loan forgiveness
program well forgiveness that was not
the question I thought you were going to
ask I didn't I I wanted to surprise you
so I think it's it's there's a couple of
things there right um we the state has
invested in marketing materials for us
to use at the national level and the
reason is is because this within the
state we don't have enough or we are not
producing enough clinicians to meet the
demands that that um exist in our state
currently so in a Senate Bill there are
investments that we've requested to do
just that so new Hampshire unfortunately
is one of the states that doesn't invest
in our area health education centers and
these organizations are designed to get
kids interested in the healthc care
profession they also help current
practitioners move up the career ladder
so I think you could um do multiple
things you should invest in programs
that develop clinicians within our state
borders but also recruit um outside of
our state borders because we do need to
do both right one isn't just the only
answer um the other thing that we would
ask is that we continue to support and
you have in the past the Coos County
family health services they have a um
Family Practice um Residency program
that they're working on getting stood up
and they expect to receive residents in
July 2026 so we need to grow our own but
we also need to help them stay here and
to that's the second part of your
question right we do need loan repayment
opportunities and the state loan
repayment program has been very
successful in helping us recruit and
retain professionals because um it's
really hard right to get someone to the
North Country to and get them to stay
there particularly if they're married or
have a partner and children because
their partner and their kids might not
have the same economic opportunities
that they do as a clinician and so the
loan repayment programs that the state
offers they kind of offset that um
unfortunate circumstance and so they've
been amazing in helping us get
clinicians into the state and stay
here would you take another one sure
okay so if you could only do one of two
things which would you do if your goal
is to uh increase the number of instate
kids going to college and to become a
health professional would you do uh a
scholarship to help them pay for school
or would you do a loan repayment after
they've already successfully graduated
you're going to hate that you ask me
this question representative Edwards no
I like the information you're the expert
teach me something it depends right so
if someone is going to school to be a
dental hygienist a scholarship upfront
is more helpful to them because their um
debt burden is lower than if you're
going to dental school so if someone's
going to Dental school scholarships are
great but what they really need is loan
repayment on the back end to help them
pay their loans down because dentists
graduate with over
$300,000 in dental school debt um dental
hygienists don't have $300,000 in
hygienist school debt so it truly
depends on what type of clinician they
are and this is why we like to do both
we have the state loan repayment program
but it would be wonderful if we did have
more scholarship
opportunities so given we have a fixed
set of money what does it seem like we
should be looking at our student loan
repayment program to diversify it so
that we could have a little bit of
relocation money so that we could have a
little scholarship money for the kid
trying to pay for school those things
are not in the in the loan repayment
program now are they um no Mr chair
they're not um but I would say that the
state loan repayment program I believe
is empty right now so it has exp it has
extended all of its contracts due to
demand and so we're relying on jua
funding for contracts at the current
moment that means that there is more
demand than the state can currently um
Supply in funds and so I I wouldn't
divert slurp I would um try and address
it a different way and I'm happy to chat
with you about ideas because we we don't
take advantage of the federal loan
repayment program
um for reasons that may have been
explained earlier so there other are
there are other opportunities that we
could look at to meet the needs of
people all right well thank you do you
have a question representative Daniels
yes thank you are there any existing CTE
programs that would uh get somebody
started on a pathway to a
clinician yes so the um area health
education centers do have um training
programs and I'm happy to get you more
information on that if that would be
helpful thank you was there a question
over
here okay question is represent
priest you I'm it's hard for me to hear
you I'm sorry um the speaker has already
answered my question thank you all right
well thank you for your testimony thank
you all right and and your and your uh
directness and your response sure and um
like Mike said we do hope that you also
come to our our legislative event on
March 20th and this time for the first
time you
serving you know what that's that's a
joke I'm sorry it's it's not in the
morning representative Edwards so we we
really hope that you can come it will be
in the evening and hopefully that will
be easier for you all right thank you
well thank you is there anyone else in
the audience that needs wants to say
something um okay so I think the next
time division 3 gets together is
tomorrow morning at 9:00 to begin
hearing like the second part of Medicaid
so so while I was
away uh chairman acting chairman money
uh held a meeting I I heard about half
of it by video and but I know that there
were still things that you all wanted to
uh address so so just re- remind
yourself of what your questions were so
that we can make that a very productive
morning yes ma'am
representative
Walmer I was wondering if the um
chairman of the finance committee has
set a date and a time for the public
hearing I think there are a lot of
people who are waiting to to hear about
the public hearing and when when it will
take
place uh the big public Hearing in the
in the house chambers that one yes yes
uh I I'm I'm not aware of a date yet U
Mr rippled have you you heard a rumor of
a date I've heard a rumor of March 12th
but I don't think it's been formally set
yet okay all right so that's the same
rumor representative Mooney herd so we
don't we don't know but if you pencil in
March 12th you might be right and I I'll
I'll follow up though the reason I asked
is because I think a lot of people who
are interested in the budget want to
make plans to come and I was also told
that that is town meeting night I I'm
from conquer I thought it was the 11th
was town meeting Town meeting's the 11th
I believe I saw one someone sent me a
screenshot New London has one on March
12th and I think there's a couple other
towns found out last time um I think
generally it's the 11 so so you you're
you serve as the um minority member for
the committee the full committee right
is that
correct okay so representative wer is
probably more available to you than to
me so
wow yeah yeah no that's how that's how
you rate so um okay I I um I I think
that's what I wanted to say Mr Ripple do
you want to finish us off do you got
anything else for us uh only that's uh
Janet sent out a notice yesterday
there's also a work session tomorrow at
1M on House Bill 71 so you'll be meeting
in the afternoon as well is that in the
is that in the calendar it wasn't in the
calendar because she only sent it out
yesterday but it's been noticed so do we
have any calendar problems having a work
session on 71 no all right good I I I
don't like calendar
problems okay well uh if that's it I
think everyone's had their say and they
they've had their fill so so thank you
so much we're
adjourned e